you have this device and you want to take which has its own tool chain which has its own like
operating system architecture everything right everything like and it's not like using the word
saying and everything on it is living in a harmony together it's just some sort of a glued
together which is like some sort of abomination that they've managed to like just make it work
and then you just want to take like one piece of that abomination and put it on the latest
linux version on your server of course it's not going to work right of course
hey guys real quick i just wanted to tell you about our sponsor threat locker now wait wait before
you hit the skip forward button let me just say this most of the stuff that holds my attention
nowadays is red team stuff as well but i sat down with the threat locker team this past week to do a
demo of their edr software and it was super technically fascinating how this thing works
so check this out you drop this thing on a system right and for the first week or so
it's creating a policy and a profile for that system it's logging all the executables what child
processes are being spawned the files and their hashes that sort of thing and it's creating this
policy okay then after the learning mode is up we're in secured mode and that policy gets put into
place and anything that's not on that allow list is immediately auto denied that's the zero trust piece
right so in addition to that they've got a bunch of crazy features like ring fencing and dynamic access
controls that would stop a malicious hacker at pretty much every step along the way actually i was
watching this demo and i was kind of freaked out because i have no idea how i would cope with getting
dropped into a threat locker system as a red teamer anyway if you want to learn more about this head over
to threatlocker.com and request a demo and when you do ask for my boy andrew his demo was super to
the point and he was able to answer all my technical questions all right cool back to the show all
righty dude i am hyped for this episode i have wanted to do a an episode with someone from pwntown
since the beginning of this podcast and finally we're having to happen so uh cena thanks so much
for coming on the pod man thanks for having me man i appreciate that i'm so delighted to be here yeah
and i really don't know why you chose me to be here to be here you've been cranking out content like
crazy lately and your bugs are are amazing so i'm sure i'm sure we'll we'll get into that a little bit
as we go into the pod but um dude i have to i have to compliment this setup before we get rolling homie's
got the dslr inflate and you got like the hat behind you and like it's it's looking fly man thanks for
putting all that effort into it thank you uh yeah i do a lot of uh photography and like uh productions
on different kind of stuff and uh yeah i sometimes use the same camera for these kind of cool meetings
that we have such as this one and yeah this uh this is actually had uh from uh pontoon oh i've got it
from there and then i've had it uh signed by i don't know if it's if you can see it but i've had it
signed by dustin childs oh really he's a he's a legend there uh he works at um trend micro zero day
initiative uh he's the head of try the awareness if i'm not wrong nice yeah i actually i actually
reached out to him when i was trying to source people for this episode and i was like hey man i
see that you kind of run ponte own um who would you recommend for this episode and and he gave me a
couple names and you you were on that list and i was like all right this is how i did a little bit of
research into it so um shout out to dustin as well for setting that up um all right dude so let's let's
spend some time okay so let me let me give a little context here so um i am a i'm someone who
participates often in the in the hacker one live hacking event scene and you are someone that
participates often in the ponte own scene right and i kind of wanted to do an episode where we discuss
the differences of these two these two worlds of bug bounty right because i feel like there's the hacker
one bug crowd integrity that sort of group and then there's like the ponte on zdi group
um and we don't see a lot of overlap from them oddly enough um and and i think there there is some
reason for that i think some of the um some of the skill sets are a little bit different um especially
with with uh ponte own and zdi primarily focusing on rce as a as a vulna class you know poning poning
as you would say a specific target um but so i i'm excited to kind of uh iron out the differences
between hacker one related live hacking events and ponte own related stuff um but i also before we jump
into all that i want to hear a little bit about you and how you got into hacking and how you ended
up at the ponte own competitions i appreciate it uh so first of all let me just start saying english is
not my first language so uh if i kind of like do like a stutter or anything yeah i hope people forgive
me if about that uh i'm trying my best kind of yeah and uh yeah so uh about uh um giving like a brief
introduction about myself i'm a full-time vulnerability researcher i've been for the last uh i don't know
how many years now uh and uh when i started uh i've actually started as a developer i was making
commercial websites with my brother when i was a kid and then uh he kind of taught me like web
development basic stuff and then we were just making websites and then uh finding customers to
sell them e-commerce websites very very simple stuff back in the day and then uh actually one of my
websites one day got hacked and then i it got d-faced um was this a bigger customer or is this a
small site or like what was the uh it was it was a small customer and then but but the problem was so
back in the day i wouldn't be i don't think people even do it nowadays but uh i would just like make
like i don't know five five backends and i've just changed the front ends for different customers because
it was it was e-commerce website right you have the shopping cart you have checkout all that stuff it's
kind of the logic is the same right very common and then so i would just exactly the very very common
components it would be like five different backends and then the front ends would be like hundreds of
different kind of front ends um and uh yeah one day one of my websites got hacked and then they would
keep getting hacked like the guy kind of like dorked it on google or something and then it was just
like finding all of them and then just like blasting all of them and then just defacing them and then just
submit him sub submitting them to these like kind of like uh you know defacing websites back from back
in the day maybe not maybe let's not name them but anyways um yeah they were just uh submitting them
and um i don't know uh getting reputation and just it was just uh defacing them and then uh when i saw it
initially i was like wow it was the first time that i was like seeing something that i made was being
hacked and then i was i was like so surprised by it and then i thought it over and i was like let's
let's actually reach out to the guy because he defaced the website and then he left out his like
email address like down the page saying like i don't know hacked by wow like this this kind of like a
cool hacker handle and then uh some sort of a country flag was on it too as well some like blood dripping
from the page you know like all this of course it's very dramatic to face and then he exactly
and then uh he had his email address there and then i reached out to him and i plugged he said
hey i made the website on the dev behind it i do this for a living and i was wondering if you can
give me some pointers on how you did it so i can prevent it from happening again so i can keep
selling my stuff and then the guy replied back to me i think after two days saying he was like i like
your i like your initiative on that you reached out to have the problem solved in some sort of a way
so he was like maybe impressed or something and then he wrote back to me uh exactly with what the
problem was and he was using all of these like complicated terminologies which back in the day i
didn't kind of understand uh like things like oh like you had a sql injection here and then after i
exploited your sql injection um i was able to uh oh the user that was your website was being running on
was like a mysql user with like root privileges and i was able to like write to a file or something
and then after i write to a file and then i managed to like visit the file and then get code execution
with my web shell and then uh the the web shell from the old school back in the day the ones that
existed back uh back in time um and then uh yeah he he did it that way and then he was uh he he was
giving me my code snippets back like marking him exactly where the bug was right right wow this was
crazy yeah um and uh and then i realized how how far he was able to go uh when just through like uh from
like an initial bug to another bug to another bug but i didn't understand like chains or whatever back
in the day um and then i was so like fascinated by like the things that he did um i've told him that
uh i'm so grateful for for the all the explanation that you did i'm actually so interested in this i i
will try to pursue it to to to make my website better and then it kind of like clicked from that
way to uh doing like a lot of searches it there there wasn't any kind of like a lot of resources whatever
you had like these i don't know like a chinese forums or a russian forum or like a yeah when was
this in the timeline was this like you know early 2000s or like when was this uh this is uh yeah yeah
something like that something like that yeah exactly yeah something like that not a lot of stuff out
there for that at that time to learn how to hack it was again way more than like something from the
90s maybe like way more but uh no you didn't have like payload all things or like something that it
was like a centralized place that had you had all the links to the to the latest techniques and tools
and tricks and bypasses and mitigations you didn't have people dropping bypasses on twitter that much as
they do now every day there's like a new bypass right right um and i was i was actually very interested
in it and then i've started like searching and searching and searching and uh translating i had
like this babylon i don't know if i'm pronouncing it right or wrong this babylon translator on my
on my desktop has just like copy paste stuff to it and then just try to understand like different kind
of languages what they were meaning and then um yeah basically uh i've got it from there and then i was
so interested in it that uh i've i've started like pursuing it and uh going after it and then trying to
learn more and more and more and then shout out to one guy who actually like played like a key role
in my in my learning curve um people don't know him that much because uh he's not he's not like
globally well known like he's not i don't i don't think even he's on twitter or something he's uh his
name is maysam uh he may sam monsif uh he was he was a teacher of mine uh back in the day that uh
taught me a lot of about web development security he was like one of these like old school hack hackers
who like learned everything by himself like he he he was from the like he was from the 80s or like
90s something and then everything by himself like uh and he was this like
still to this day he's he was like a legend to me back in the day and he had like played like a very
very key role in my learning path and uh teaching me a lot of things he helped me to build like a
strong foundation in um algorithm and understanding like coding and everything not just copy pasting
and like just like um like he he built like a really good foundation for me and then that kitty stuff
yeah exactly like he like i can't tell you how much of a strong foundation he had he has even still
to this day i'm sure uh and uh that that like taught me a lot about if you understand the architecture
actually instead of just copy pasting payloads and just just getting your way if you understand
how actually things work that takes you like a lot of extra mile yeah yeah and and and i think so i
think it's really interesting that you started out from web dev and then you went to web hacking right
and and i think that's a pretty traditional flow for the the people in exactly in the hacker one scene
as well as like you know now we're focusing on these these web bugs and and like idor and access
control related stuff right but then you know instead of going down this path of like oh let me identify
all these web bugs and and do web related stuff quite as much you end up somehow in the the you
know binary exploitation scene as well um so what was that what was that progression like uh as a hacker
like when did you start switching from all right i'm finding sqls in in php code to all right let me load
this thing up in in ghidra or whatever and and start reverse engineering it uh that's actually a great
question so exactly back in the day at that time that i started like working on web stuff um the
the same guy this the same guy that i knew he was actually an expert in like low level exploitation
uh like um and he he was very good at it uh like he was like this like cc plus plus guru and then he
was able to like craft exploits for like kernel drivers and everything and he was he was just like
just genius and then uh we were actually so we didn't have access to like idah and ghidra wasn't
a thing back there and like a lot of these assemblers that you see nowadays weren't a thing so we were
just like using like all the dbg uh if i'm pronouncing the name right yeah yeah so it was this is yeah
it's like one of these like you know like one of these like really ancient uh powerful very very very
powerful debuggers that i still see to this day people use so he told me he told me that um listen
like you can use this like tool and um i don't have time he didn't he didn't have a lot of time
in his hand he wasn't like a personal tutor or something but just he was like more like a friend
uh and then he kind of like encouraged me to go learn like assembly and so he was he was very like
um he was very strict with foundation so he wasn't like okay you just open this up you just drag and
drop something here you look for this and that and click click click done or like copy paste stuff
it was he was very strict with building a strong foundation and then uh that's why i've i i went out
and then like i started like buying books and stuff about like learning assembly how did you like like
hello world uh we had like a some sort of like a local hacker meetup kind of thing back in the day
that uh yeah yeah exactly and then i was just trying to like connect with people to to learn from and
stuff and then i didn't i didn't end up making any friends but i did end up meeting this guy and then
the way that i met this guy was actually through like initially i thought he's just a web dev guy
uh but he was way more to to what i thought he was uh he he was he was he was super humble
super humble uh super humble guy that he didn't just start like blabbering about okay i know this
i'm like the jack of all trades or whatever he was actually like he was actually very he
like he was a ninja like he is still to this day like and and he was he was also a great teacher which uh
which not everybody can teach yeah you can be great at what you do but that's a rare overlap you
know if you can if you have the ability to to especially be a jack of all traits have such a a
high amount of knowledge and then be able to teach and then furthermore to be able to teach in such a
way that you give the the student the right foundation and allow them to almost learn for
themselves exactly teach them how to learn um how to get you know some of these skills along the way so
that's man what what a what a blessing this guy was to you and it seems like he was really key in
your development exactly yeah he he was like a he he was like a high booster for me um and uh if i am
anything today uh i haven't reached much today but uh if i have like reached anything like that you can
like count it uh it it goes back to the roots of uh meeting with him and uh basically yeah he encouraged
me like building the foundation and then uh after like started like reading about like exactly at the
so at the same time so i would like divide my day to doing like okay i'm gonna do i'm gonna do web
stuff i'm gonna learn about like sql injection like i don't know like uh i don't know local file
inclusion remote file inclusion this this and that and then serialization and whatever back in the day
and then i would i would be also doing uh dedicating some like uh three four hours to reverse engineering
building building up the foundation like learning uh learning assembly and learning all of that and
then there wasn't again there wasn't much resources but the ones that were available were actually good
enough and um um and you know like at least for me uh i think it was pretty important that things were
more difficult back in the day and that kind of helped me to to struggle more and to try more
uh so nowadays when i now this that things are i think pretty much i i think it kind of it's more
i don't want to exactly it's more developed right i've maybe maybe using the word easier will
will like offend someone not easier but it's like more accessible to people absolutely uh yeah and then
that that helps more into like finishing something um and then i think the not having a lot of available
things uh as much as today compared to back then uh it kind of helped in uh like developing that kind
of like intuition to not give up and then just just keep trying and keep trying and keep studying and
keep studying and keep studying without thinking that when does it get over because it never gets
over exactly it's just endless that's that's one of the things i always tell to the students that i work
with is like listen um you know you can read all these tutorials and you can go out there and and like you
said a lot of the content is made really accessible nowadays um but the real learning is going to occur
when you get out there and you fail and you fail and you fail and you fail and you fail and you fail
you know but but there's a there's a finite number of failures between you know now and the next time
that you pop a crazy bug right and so you just got to get out there and start knocking those out of the
way um because experience is going to be the best teacher in a lot of these scenarios you know you see
some of these newer guys just looking at http requests and they're like man i i have no idea what all of
these headers mean you know and i'm like all right well just look it up real quick you know and and
you got to pay the price to know you know what these things are and then once you started knocking
them out once you started doing some reps on it um you know you'll sort of get a sense for what's
interesting and what's not interesting um and i think it's we've kind of inversely switched into a
different problem now which i see a lot of a lot of people fall into which is um what we call education
procrastination which is you're just constantly learning reading reading learning learning and
you never get to the actual doing part um and and i think it's it's so important for beginners to get
out there even if you don't feel like you know what you're doing even if you're just stabbing in the
dark to just get out there and fail and have that be a key part of your your education process
um i don't want to i don't want to sound like a guy who was just going to say exactly yes i agree with
that but but you're speaking facts so um exactly i i agree with that and then uh as corny as it sounds
like when when you tell people nowadays to try harder go at it like as you said do the reps or
like fail and fail and fail and all that it sounds like all of these like because nowadays there is
like all of these motivational videos or like people trying to like sell you a course to help
how to become a billionaire and using the same actual sentences as we are saying right here
it might kind of like cancel out in some people's mind that okay we're just trying to make it make it
sound difficult even though it isn't but it like if if you want to do like cool like you gotta you gotta
do the reps you gotta you know you gotta you gotta build this right you gotta fail and fail and fail and
debug and debug and debug and then just like these muscles right develop that thing
yeah i think uh you gotta start another separate channel for uh bodybuilding
i know you said you hit the gym right before this episode so maybe you and i will do a uh you know a
gym episode in vegas or something like that um okay yeah all right so yeah you said you know okay
so you you met this guy and he and he really helped you with a foundation of okay so we're
working on sql injection and then we're switching over to you know reverse engineering for a couple
hours and we're really kind of getting a great foundation um in place and and so i'm i'm curious
you know as this foundation starts going in in in place one how are you feeling as you're building all
this right because you're not actively out there like popping exploits and stuff like that you're
you're building a lot of this foundation so are you feeling antsy or are you just kind of like
you're like uh maybe this isn't the right path or you are you kind of trusting that this is the right
path and uh just kind of being really interested in the stuff that you're learning at the time
um i did uh this is a question for at the time right yeah right i was doing it yeah so
i didn't have any perspective of what i'm gonna do like i i didn't think there would be a job even
there is like a cyber security job and vulnerability nothing i was just i just wanted to get like
shells just wanted to get just wanted to like get the get the rush when you exploit something and that
and also the pause between these rushes that you're spending time to find a bug so that pause kind of
like would build that expectation and then when you like satisfy the expectation of okay i i hit it now
i've i've got a shell i popped the calc i popped ms paint whatever like i just wanted to do it i i
didn't have any idea like yeah it's addicting and then at the time um so one one might ask like okay
then how would you were like making a living like you couldn't just like stay at home and just doing
this so i had like my developer geek and then i would just like uh try to like make money out of that
and then i tell you like like 24 7 like 24 7 like uh i would just get to get to get like the client
project done or whatever and the good thing with the development jobs like as i told you like you
had like i don't know like 10 back backends and you just like change the front ends whatever and then
sometimes like minor modifications in order to like sell that kind of like a cms or whatever the product
you had at the time and then uh yeah i would just like be like my whole world like was just that just
to reverse engineer or do source code review and just find bugs and i would just go on like any kind
of like a website that would say okay this is a trial of our product this is a demo of this like
open source closed source whatever just take it just test out everything like fail and fail and just
go go into this like different rabbit holes and i literally didn't like i kid you not like i would
just install the software and i'd be like okay what am i gonna do next okay what what am i even going
look at attack surface attack surface was a joke i didn't know what an attack surface was i couldn't
even like like i would just install it and i'd be like okay i'm just gonna interact with this right
thing and then understand if can go wrong at a certain point exactly just like just like that right
and then um as i was doing this and just reading and reading and reading and all of that and kind
of like you know it goes kind of like those like you know it's like the classic classic story of
background story of everyone else like they started from somewhere they they did that they did their
time they paid the i don't know pay the dues or whatever yeah and then after a while they exactly
and then uh they build it up i did decided and then uh and then after a point like your skills just
get sharper and sharper at the time and then yeah i remember like uh i have told you like it was it was
24 7 like i would just like work until like 12 or 1 p.m and i would just sleep until like 6 7 and i
would just wake up same screen same screen just just looking at just like reversing testing right i mean
i i think yeah one of the common themes that we see is is you know in the beginning you didn't know
that this was a job right and i think that's one of yeah i love bug bounty like book bounty is is one
of the most amazing things in my life for sure but i do think there's been a con to bug bounty a little
bit which is people focus on the bounty right people focus on my delimiter for success with learning
hacking is whether or not i'm getting bounties or not and that's not how it's supposed to be right
you need to love hacking you need to love the process of growing and hacking you need to love the
process of um you know seeing this piece of software and just like understanding how it works
and understanding its little nuances that you can you know that you can break that and and not to say
that people can't just do bug bounty as a job people can do bug bounty as a job and if you're not
super mega passionate about it i'm not trying to like gatekeep a bounty from you but um i think to to
to get to this level where you're like finding super crazy stuff and you're and you're um just
absolutely loving your job like there has to be that focus on hacking as a as a passion first and
then you're like oh wait you know this is a this can be a job too um so i always tell try to tell
people to release that whole expectation of bounty in the beginning and just more focus on like hacking
as an art and as a craft right you got a point there and let's say let me also mention this right so
at the time when i was doing it and a lot of other people um the the whole thing was like a dark path
that you didn't know where you're going and uh like you didn't have like a centralized place with all the
attack surfaces and all the attack lists and all the kind of like the what's available or whatever
it was kind of like a dark path and we're just like going and then you try to like light up the whole
like different alleys and different like the streets and whatever on this path just just slowly but
nowadays i don't know if what what's it called in like what's the right term but it's like uh when you
have a huge amount of information available now and then when you want to start you kind of get shocked
right you get scared you're like there's so much to learn like you're like so exactly you get overloaded
you're like oh my god like i don't know if i can i don't know if i want to start this because it's too
much like how am i supposed to like learn all of this but um which which which adds a different kind
of difficulty to to to today's people that like are starting it or have started it right uh back in
the day different problems now different problems right and then you have a lot of competitors and like
uh different kind of stuff adds up adds up to it as well uh i think you just like just start right
just like just keep doing it just just learn as you go just just learn don't think about all the
possible like all the what's available just just try to learn it slowly like building it just like go
go with it go with like a normal pace and going and going and just like build it up and um don't get
don't get distracted a lot and then i don't know i don't know how to put it i think i think at a
certain point i'm just keep repeating myself well i i think i think i think you're repeating yourself
because this is a part of the process you know is is just going down that pathway and and like you said
figuring out as you go um and i love that you acknowledged that there's difficulties to modern
day education and bug bounty too because i think that's a really fair assessment of it is that
you know back in the day we had too little information but now we've got too much information
and it's hard to balance those two right um and and so the only way to balance those two is get out
there and do it um and so that's why i always talk about you know i've got pinned to my twitter profile
sort of like a um a blueprint for how to get started in bug bounty and essentially what i say is
in the beginning you know do 80 learning 20 hacking you know and then you move up to 60 learning 40
hacking and then it's 60 hacking 40 learning right and but notice how there's always some hacking
involved in there you know like um you have to be out there actually doing the hacking um for you to
get reps so i i think that's really i think that's really important um so okay so that's a little bit
of your of your background you you kind of started with this really rigorous um you know training and
you were doing it for the for the passion of it um and you didn't even know that this could turn into
a job um but so when did that that web development scale out and when did you start working as a as a uh you
know as an offensive security expert or vulnerability research yep so uh i i was just like uh doing this
like uh just doing it for myself just like trying to exploit stuff and just like having my exploit python
files in my like local local drive and just like looking at them and feeling like i i like i ruled the
world or whatever it's just like just just just getting high on that and then uh after after like
like going again and again and again just like for exploiting different kind of stuff uh at a certain
point i was sort of like hearing interacting with the kind of like other people and then like hearing
about okay like there's a thing like cyber security roles like pentester roles and all of that and so
it wasn't like vulnerability researcher or whatever it's just we had this only one title back in there
pentester are you a pentester or not that's it yeah yeah so i started like i said like a pentester um and
then just like normal stuff like i don't know attacking active directory um different kind of
like attacking active directory and network scanning uh like vulnerability scanning different kind of
tools this and that and that and then just like what what like usual people do not nothing nothing
fancy just like but i always try to like do like that extra mile i would just like bring uh even though i
don't recommend it to people like this this doesn't sound this this doesn't sound right to people and people
just prohibits doing the prohibits doing this but i did it better back in the time because i didn't
do it for the companies that i work for i just did it for myself i just like bring work home and just
trying to go that extra mile to like find something fascinating or find something interesting
if if it was just like a network pentest maybe i can find some sort of a custom software that i could
like find like a heap overflow in it and then i just like craft an exploit for it how hard could it be
it's a windows xp it's not like a windows 11 or whatever which is like all the mitigations or you
like even there is there's ways to this but it was way easier right i'll just try to like go that
extra mile to try to apply my i would i would make up like i would like make targets up like my boss
would have told me okay just test this this software and that software and that software that's
that's what we're being paid for right uh you can test these as well but we're not getting paid for
i was like okay i want to test those as well i'll just bring it home yeah i'll just like work on them
and work on them and all of that and that's great yeah i mean that that was sort of the same same sort
of thing that i had which was like okay first you get in that pentester role right and then the next
step is like master master that and like get it so that you can get very satisfactory results um
quickly you know let's say it's a 40 hour test you're you're popping everything and getting it done in
like 20 hours right and then that extra 20 hours you've got is like additional value add to the
client okay and by the way here's a zero day in this library you're using or like exactly you know
that's that's perfect man and and that that's exactly what what i did as well i think that's a
really good takeaway is like um you know go for these go the extra mile on these engagements but i
think a lot of people try to skip that first step which is first master what you're what you're supposed
to do you know master that that that um initial pen test where you can get the results you know that
you need for the client quickly and then you've got that margin either at work or like you said at home
um to go the extra mile and and and uh you know build out these extra exploits and and apply the
knowledge that you you're getting through your own study to these targets that you're working on um
that's that's awesome man okay cool so that so then you know you're in that pentesting environment
you're growing you're growing and then do you stay as a pentester long term are you switching into
vulnerability research and and where does ponte to own fit into this whole equation yeah uh so i was
just like doing like these pentester roles and then just like going through the ranks i don't know like
a junior senior media or whatever right just going up and then um and then uh i at the same time that
i was like learning all of these like bug bounty was being like promoted a lot and all that and people
were getting more into bug bounty even though there were people doing it way back like people were
doing it like exactly the same day like hacker one was launched and then uh like people were doing it
like all that but it was getting like more promoted and like all that and then um i've kind of i i've
kind of started trying it and then i wasn't good at it um i did i did make some money i i like i i did
some make money i did make some money and then like i was just like targeting different kind of things and
the uh the good thing to be honest uh maybe maybe if i would have like pursue it back then like it
would have been better instead of like giving up on it because people were there wasn't much automation
back there that's today yeah so so if if you were clever enough to make some sort of automation like
in a day you would be like drowning in money yeah and uh but i i kind of like i i didn't like i didn't
click with the whole concept i wasn't probably because i wasn't like pretty much good at it but
i did make some money i was like reporting to microsoft and all of that and then uh which was
good i was like making good money microsoft was paying microsoft uh was paying a lot of money back
in the day i think compared to today maybe i don't know uh but what happened was uh to answer your
question one day as i was like any other day that i was just like watch five or six conference videos
from different kind of things that would come up to to try to like find my own niche or whatever i've
i saw a video in often a hack in the box conference um from steven steely i think you know how classic
i saw yeah i saw one of his talks and um when i saw it like he it was like so fascinating to me i was
like i've got to do exactly what this guy does and i've like started like googling his name reading
whatever he wrote and then get familiar with his blog and all of that reading all of his exploits
and all of that and then one thing that i was one thing that i learned as i was like doing all of this
stuff was trying to reproduce other people's work i can't stress how important it is today even though
not even even though now even even it's easier today today to do it but i don't think much people
are doing it like you have like docker images that people will set up 10 minutes after the cv comes up
you can just do like a docker start and then you have the already vulnerable image set up port exposed
you have a sample of the payload and then you can just like fire it and test it right and then people
like start like making all like nuclei stuff and like just like a spray through the whole internet or
whatever right and a lot of other stuff that i'm not aware of right that's just the thing that i know
uh but back in the day right people just like publish the exploit and then uh people weren't doing
like end day analysis and all of that but i know to be honest nobody told me to do it i was just i was
just thinking okay i want to do exactly what steven silly does right i i want to get to his level
even though he's like way way farther like that i can even look at right he's just like on like this
whole like a different mountain and then i was like okay okay maybe the best thing is if i read
these blogs and i don't understand it i would just write down everything that i don't understand even
from a simple word that says i don't know something like i don't know whatever just write it down and
then just like it starts it's not like slowly building up my foundation to understand his blogs
and then let's let's install the same software let's try to find same bug let's let's just try to do the
same thing as he did and keep failing at it and just keep doing it and keep doing it i've tried to
reproduce as much as advisories and exploits that he had published uh and then and then i've kind of like
i was i was feeling that i'm stepping in the same shoe as he has i was just like stepping in the same
shoe and then i i've i've i've started like developing that kind of like intuition like just like close not
exactly just close like just trying to like be like him right a a well-known a well-known like experienced
experienced expert vulnerability researcher who who's a who has done you anything you could think
of like back in the day he was like making making heap exploitation plugins to do like crazy stuff so
he's not just like this like high level guy who's only doing like this kind of like one area he he has
done it everything you can think of he has done like low level exploitation hardware embedded high level
stuff like exotic architecture whatever you could think of right he has done it like the like he he
became and he is still to this day my role model even even uh even on my blog if you go there like
there's like about page on top i put his name saying like this this is one of the guys who had like direct
uh direct like uh impact on what i am today even if i am anything today but um yeah basically uh i've kind
of like started following his path just going after what he did and all the things i just i just said
before that's and that's that's really great dude because i think i think um you know when you see
somebody like that and they're inspiring you know you it's easy to be like yeah i want to be like that
and then like just think about get sort of fixated on the end goal like wouldn't it be cool if i was
like you know a vulnerability researcher if i like did this for a career or whatever and then instead
of focusing on that end goal you start reverse engineering it you say like okay well in order to
get to where he was he did all these bugs so i'm gonna go back and you know try to reproduce all these
bugs and you know make it so that i could have found these um so i like how you reverse engineered
uh you know stephen seeley as well that's great you know uh you apply that reverse engineering stuff to
your you know your role model there in that capacity as well um and that's that's that's great um
um so i guess where i want to go from here is i want to talk about uh i want to do one more section
in the uh you know about you area and talk about your favorite bugs and and how those have evolved
over the years as you you know gained more capabilities and then i kind of want to move into
your hacking methodology specifically and how you've been popping all these bugs on all these targets
nowadays for for bone to own and um and and even outside of that um and it's very source code
analysis heavy uh so i'm excited to talk about that as well so start with what are your favorite bugs that
you find a lot and then kind of move into your hacking methodology uh nowadays that the more stuff that i
find that are like more interesting to me are more more like memory corruption kind of stuff either
it's like a vulnerability like a kernel driver mostly like linux based uh or is it like embedded device
or like a something else right more memory corruption oriented kind of stuff are like uh like my like
top favorite kind of stuff to do and uh i also like what but the things that i'm that i'm allowed or
able to blog about is mostly like the high level stuff that i find which are like either deserialization
path traversal you know like your simple stuff like non-memory corruption kind of stuff any everything
that all the other people are finding i'll just i just love to explain uh code and just go through that
um and just like build it up from there and uh it's it's exactly like uh projecting the way um at least
i'm trying to i'm basically copying um that's why i'm saying like maybe projecting is not the right word but
the work that steven has been doing over years and years because he's like the source code exactly
he puts on the source code and then he just like starts building up saying um i don't know the source
is from here and then we reach the sink right we go to this whole path and then um i've tried to try to
uh like uh do the same thing as he he was doing and he has been doing um and uh yeah um like but
my my favorite kind of stuff are like memory corruption stuff but uh one of one of my also
other favorite kind of things to do is like any dot net related vulnerabilities uh and i'm just and
i'm not just saying that to promote my own training even though i have a training people are like
uh welcome to do that's amazing and i'm so happy um i haven't announced it yet but i'm so happy to
say like i have like august august training uh coming up and uh it just it it has been like filled up no
right congrats i've had thank you like it had like 25 seats 24 seats have been filled up and i'm i'm so
happy about it and uh like it's crazy like uh uh when i started like making the training i thought
like you know you get whenever you want whatever you want to start you you think like i don't know
like maybe maybe nobody likes it or maybe nobody can't but you know like if you build it they'll
they'll show up or whatever exactly and then uh i've exactly i i try to like give it as a workshop
different places and just like going to different countries and different conferences and doing it and
then people people were nice enough to to post like feedbacks and stuff and that feedback helped on
uh promoting the training for other people to show up and then i've had like 15 registrations uh 15 or
14 registrations uh until like i don't know three weeks ago or something two weeks ago and then after
i published i dropped like three exploit three exploits at the same time three blog posts um with a uh
with a privilege escalation uh after i dropped those uh three blog posts uh saying that i'm doing this
to promote my training and then uh people like started like 14 13 other people signed up for the
training which was which was pretty cool to me to to get publicity to that and you found a way to add
value to the community so you know you drop this this blog post everyone's reading through this they're
like wow this this rocks and then you know you've got oh let me check out this guy in his course um so
that's that's really exciting man and you know this pod is going to drop soon so you need to get
another you need to get another class that people can sign up for maybe like a wait list or something
because i'm sure a lot of the listeners podcast would love to uh to sign up and check out this class
especially if you want to get into this um a little bit deeper realm right like a lot of the stuff that
we talk about here is um is some you know web-related vulnerabilities and stuff like that but one of the
things we stress all the time is is if you can get your hands on source code man that is so sweet
like like if there's any possibility of you remotely being able to get your hands on source code
uh it's amazing and with dot net stuff um that's more and more possible um and so yeah definitely
definitely check out this course if you're interested uh we'll link it down in this description
um and and so i guess when you're dealing with dot net stuff how do you how do you how do you
approach that what is your give us a little bit of insight into your methodology for dot net
yep so uh what i do is no magic like i just do the same thing as many other people have been doing for
years and years and years there is to be honest with you like the reason there isn't complete like
there isn't much of a secret sauce it's just it's just doing the same people do but i just i i don't do
it like once i do it a thousand times and then others a thousand times maybe five targets are vulnerable
and then people only see the end result of the blog post coming up right uh but uh i just like
keep doing the same thing and then i'll start like picking up things um um with dot net basically you
you you'll after you like acquire the software whatever that you think worth investigating either
it's a well-known i don't know like um if it's like well-known software such as like exchange or
sharepoint or like a solar winds product right like these are like well-known products um you get them
you acquire them and then you just like install the software and then you start to map out the attack
surface but in order to map out the attack surface you need to understand like uh like you're working
with like a dot net target the good thing with dot net is when you can decompile dot net and get get
it get almost like the exact code that was written initially to like decompile it which is amazing
like like like java ideas like you can like decompile it uh even that it hasn't been like uh you know
like minified or obfuscated which is sometimes a problem but uh there are ways for that as well so
what are you using for that did did you mean so like are you using dot peak or or
uh yeah so there are a lot of soft versions you can use you can use dot peak
rider from jet brains you can use i'll spy dnspy visual studio you can use all of those uh and and
i sometimes switch between them sometimes for some reason one of them doesn't work and they do like
okay let's let me try the other one or whatever do you have a preference uh it's your first go to i
yeah i usually go with the most generic one people use dnspy that's like that's my favorite but but i
know a lot of experts who use like visual studio uh it's a bit it maybe it's a bit like uh it takes
just like a if you haven't done it before it maybe takes you like like an hour to to to figure out how
to do it but uh just the first time but you can use like visual studio too but i use like usually dnspy
has always worked for me um the latest version of dnspy is called dnspy x because dnspy was abandoned
dns and then uh yeah dnspy x and then it's funny um on a like a non-related kind of thing the the guy
who's been developing dnspy x for the last like i think four years maybe five years he's like this
like 19 year old 20 year old kid no way uh who yeah he's like he's like a self-taught developer his name
is uh his handle is electro kill yeah if i'm not wrong and is this like genius kind of dude who's
like been adding a lot of features to to the project and just taking the project by his own
uh people commit but the majority of the like crucial commits are from having uh things that
are like involved around the engine love people like that they do that do that massive service to
the community and when you said dnspy i i went to the old repo and i was like man this hasn't been
touched in like four years i'm kind of surprised you're still using this but um yeah no it makes sense
that with dns by x and that's ex by the way i i searched dns by just the letter x and it didn't
come up so dns by ex um yeah very cool yeah and i know i know that uh that joel is a little bit more
of a uh of a fan of um dot peak and and that whole uh family of products over there but i think it's
definitely worthwhile to switch between the two because there are some weird things sometimes where
one will reverse it and the other one won't and i've seen this in java plenty of times as well
because there's so many java decompilers as well yeah so usually like uh giving giving out some
pointers to people this is this is well known this is like a couple of like well-known things this is
not something that i like that i only know or like like like a like a secret knowledge or whatever but
uh with dotnet sometimes you try to like debug a process and then for some reason uh either you're
not like you you attach to the process and then you like start putting breakpoints and then indian
spy or whatever kind of thing that you're using and then the breakpoints won't be set the software
kind of like gives you such an error so i'm saying that i can't set a breakpoint here or you do set
a breakpoint um on different places and then you go and uh in these like debuggers right whenever your
breakpoint hits you can look at the local variables global variables whatever right it's called locals
and then you can start looking at them but um for some reason you get errors when you try to find
their value like the software is looking into the memory to to to find the value or whatever uh doing
some sort of like things behind the scene but you're not able to see it that's because with dotnet at
least there can be different reasons but one of the reasons which happens like 70 of the time
is because the image so dot so we call dotnet executables like images right we can call anything
image but this dotnet executable or image or select dll or whatever it has been optimized uh when you
execute a dotnet uh dot project uh dot that runtime will optimize this dll's and uh and make them in a
way that the debugger isn't able to uh like peek into the values so you need to de-optimize this kind of
like uh de-optimize this uh like the images and in order to do so there's like there's a lot of like
not a lot but there's like three or four blog posts out there that says like how to do it basically you
create a ini file next to the uh image name and then you just like put some some sort of a allow optimize
uh and some other things in there and you switch their values to disable them and then and then you
just like kill the process or like restart the restart the process whatever and then now the next time
that it comes up the uh the image isn't optimized anymore and then the debugger can easily break
point anywhere uh work with multi-threaded applications look at locals and everything
because dotnet has a lot of concepts of uh optimization uh global assembly cache and um some other stuff
called engine and next generation like engine kind of like images which basically all kind of uh it can
be explained way more but just like to put it like an end to the concept is the image has been optimized
to run faster or run more efficient so the debugger can't really work with it for some reason you need
to de-optimize it by putting the ini file next to it and then you all sort it you're going to start like
debugging this that's awesome and i just want to shout out as well just some of the copy that was
in your in your um uh sort of description for your course it was like hey guys listen this is 80 stuff
that's that's out there and 20 stuff that's special to me but you know why should i pay for something
that's 80 public and 20 not you answer that question so alec eloquently which is like like this is
this is how people learn about stuff is getting all of these these that 80 squared away and there's a lot
more than just that 80 out there so if you're swimming in this sea of knowledge right and and
what you're doing with this course is giving them that that 80 that they need right and uh and and i
think that's absolutely uh pivotal you know when you come against this scenario um and you're just
trying to set up a debugger on this thing and you're like i can't get it to set the break points
or whatever um that sort of knowledge is is absolutely pivotal so what you're paying for with
this course is a way to to lower you know to narrow in on the stuff that you need to be more
high performing in a dot net environment which i think is is very high value um so yeah one thing
i apologize for jumping in but one thing i want to say i i always say that like i kind of like these
do these like small workshops which are a couple of hours which is like the which is you know like
the sample of the training of what what you will get when you come up for the training uh to try to
promote my training you know just like many other people have been doing for years right just just
you you gotta you gotta start like doing it promoting yourself and then i i tell this to
people a lot genuinely the course is expensive and i really don't recommend it if if you're some sort of
a uh student or like a like a solo person who's like making an earning by himself to to come up to the
course even though even though i would love saying that oh come up to my course i'll teach you everything
doesn't matter like who you are but i i genuinely say this like uh if you're an individual it just
doesn't add up spending that much money for a training even though who doesn't love students
for me it's generating money right but it's i think it's mostly preferred if you're working for an
organization or a company that the company is investing in these like employees in these vulnerability
researchers to come to somebody's training who who's advertising that he can like take you from
the basics to pretty pretty pretty advanced in dot and exploitation uh for that company the price makes
sense but for an individual or for a student it doesn't and i get a lot of emails from people uh who
are students so sorry i get a lot of people from uh email from people um sending me emails saying like
they're kind of like a student and can you give us a discount or whatever and i'll be and i have
given them discounts for those people and they've actually signed up but i always say this like uh
you just you can learn all of these by yourself all of this yourself just don't think you have to come
to my training or anybody's training you can learn all of this yourself that's how i learned it you can
just search the titles go to the blocks each block will at least have at least will have one or two
references to other blocks and this just goes like a like a whole web of stuff and then just like keep
keep following in and then after you like follow these kind of stuff you you next thing you know like
eight months eight months later nine months later you you like you have like a pretty pretty good
foundation now so this is just the fast you know like if you're trying to do it if you're trying to get
it quickly if you're trying to understand exactly what you need and i like also that it makes me
trust i haven't taken your course and and uh you know we haven't done any deals on like you know
promoting your course for this podcast but i think i'm much more likely to take your course because of
what you just explained about foundations and like and and how much this guy helped you and how how much
that was a part of your learning experience because what you want out of these fast track courses is
not like solve all my problems what what what you need is like give me the tools that i need to
solve my own problems right when i go up against these targets so i i think that's really encouraging
um so but i do want to push back a little bit on something you said which was that this is for
organizations because um i mean how much does this course cost uh it costs like uh three thousand pounds
british pounds which show four thousand dollars maybe you need to yeah and then you need to like
uh and then when people go start paying that they they see they see the tax as well on the money and
then they're like oh this is too much money which makes sense and um uh and what i wanted to say
so sorry to interrupt but what i wanted to say with this was like if you've if you're a bug bounty hunter
and you're just a solo solo bug bounty hunter right i do this full time i would have no qualms paying for
this course out of my own my own company you know my own earnings right because i know that if i use
the techniques in this course um and i i apply this and i get one just one rce out of this on some of
these more enterprise grade targets that pays out much much more than this four thousand dollars that
i'm that i'm i'm paying and i i have just walked away with all those skills right so not only do i get
roi but i get the skills as well so i i just think you know from from my perspective i think bug bounty
hunters are a little bit i don't know i think there's something about them that that makes them
want to go this this route of like you know learn it all yourself build all the tools yourself that
sort of thing and i think that's excellent um but for the people that are wanting are getting frustrated
with their bug bounty journey and they want to expedite the process a little bit um and then you
know maybe pivot out of a job where they're unhappy or something like that doing something like this
paying the money up front and then expecting to see an roi i think is a great is a great move um and
a move that i don't see enough people do invest in their own education so yeah like four days 32 hours
like you you you understand like like 90 percent 95 of what you need like and and in the training
it it's it is a long course and like all the targets are like real world softwares that i've
like exploited or like other people have exploited i'll bring it in the class we'll have set it up and
then we'll just go through the whole chain uh like a lot of bugs more than like 25 bugs a lot of chains
and like like all the areas like you like fully understand all the serializers that are that are
out there for dotnet not just like running by social and if it fails if it fails whatever actually
being able to like craft chains gadget chains and like making exploit chains and all of that and going
through that it to be honest like it is it is pretty pretty much as i said valuable and i understand
you're saying like bug bounty punters um i don't know if it's the right word to use but might have
the luxury to to be able to afford such trainings to to get that roi but um again and and i love
students who who doesn't love the students i love anybody who wants to sign up i'm happy to i i'm i'm
making a living i will do my part to give the training and i'll also make getting the money out of it
uh but if you're like if you're a person watching this listening to this whatever right if if you
open the website because back in the day this this is what happened to me and i i and i feel and i feel
for these people right uh because this happened to me you opened up the website you see the syllabus you
see the guy who's teaching it you're like oh okay you first if you get first you need to get convinced
if the guy knows his right and then you're like okay okay he he he might know something right i
believe he knows something i want to go to training sounds interesting but this is too much money i can't
afford it don't don't let that to stop you from pursuing dotnet exploitation just do it like just
copy paste the syllabus that i have and just keep searching you have a you have a problem you don't
understand it i put my email out there just copy paste it send an email saying can you give me some
references that i want to understand this topic or that topic i'm happy to do so i don't want to
hold it back because because i'm not you're not taking out anything from me it is something that i
learned from other people as well i'm just giving you references to go learn it it will take me five
minutes to give you that link to go learn it and and people have and and i i i've said this is not the
first time i'm saying this i've said that in like different like classes and conferences i've been to
and this has actually impacted people and they've they've wrote they have been writing the email
saying oh we want to understand like how to exploit this kind of serializer that has been implemented
in dotnet can you give can afford the training can you give us some references on places that we can go
read about this whatever right and i and i've like sent them links i'm i'm happy to that's a that's a
great offer don't don't let people don't let that to stop you you can do it absolutely like what nine
months eight months one year if you if you do it constantly you do it like that like it's nothing
it's easy it's not black magic it's not it's not like secret knowledge i've learned that by googling
you can do it too uh yeah yeah no that's sorry that's a great offer man i think i think um yeah i think
that you know you kind of open up the floodgates a little bit there so be careful because what will end up
happening is is you'll you'll you'll start getting you know people messaging you it's fine to be
honest that's that's great well hey man take advantage of this uh offer while it lasts with with
him because um you know at some point he's going to get to the point where he can't um he can't reply
reply to all of them so while while he he's offering this uh take advantage of it okay so um yeah
so see now i want to i want to move over to a topic that you sort of mentioned before and then uh
something you also have in the notes saying that a debugger is super important to you um and i have
a little confession to make here on the pod i have not set up a debugger on like an active debugger on a
on a target that i've worked on before i've done so much uh you know white box um you know source code
review that sort of thing but it's always been me looking at the code me crafting an exploit me sending
it in and then being like you know why the frick isn't this working you know and not having any
introspection into it and when i think about the luxury of having a debugger i'm like oh man that
would make this process so much easier um so for for those of us that haven't actually had um that
experience before can you talk a little bit about what that adds to you and then how just at a high
level how how difficult it is to set it up in various environments like a java environment or a
or a.net environment uh that's actually a really good question even i was the same back in the day i'm
would like look at the source code if it was like a web app and i'd be like okay this is a function
it's checking to like input arguments from the query string or maybe the post body or whatever
or maybe a header i can see it clearly in this code and then it's it's i don't know passing it to like a
sql query without sanitization okay i understand it i just need to hit the same phone with my
rep suite or whatever and provide these arguments and then i will hit it right and most of the times
that works right yeah um but at a certain point in time you you come across applications which are
far more complicated uh and then for some reason you're trying to send those parameters or whatever
either it's a tc it's a tcp server which has been written in cc plus plus that you need gdb to attach to
it's a compiled binary or it's a dot net target which you need to attach dnspire to it or it's like a java
target which you need to attach like its own debugger to it either it's uh i don't know like
a unit you can use like jetbrains products or any kind of other product you want to use to to debug to
debug it and then for some reason you're not hitting that endpoint the website is i don't know you're
giving like a 404 or an unauthorized or whatever if you're doing only source code review and it's like
a huge application you might think um why doesn't it work should i move on maybe the code is dead or
whatever or maybe something you don't know that thing right somebody's inside my brain you don't
know the thing that's exactly what i say in my brain i'm like why is this working i could see the source
code like exactly you say like i'm seeing it like either see my decompiler disassembler or whatever
i'm seeing it like why isn't it being hit but when you attach a debugger to that like to that target
say like a java target you like use like uh many debuggers for java but like i usually use like jetbrain's
product for java targets you you attach to it and then you understand okay there is a filter or an
interceptor or a middleware which is which is like way way way before this route gets called and that's
looking for a certain header that i'm not sending it and that's why for example i'm not reaching the
sync to reaching this function or whatever that helps or sometimes you want to bypass mitigations
and you want to keep testing for it or or fuzz the behavior or whatever when you attach a debugger you
can in most of these in most of these uh debuggers you can start uh writing expressions right you can
write java code or dot net code uh or like peek into the memory or change stuff and then call a function
again and again and again and then that kind of like speeds up your analysis and your understanding
i'd say so uh exactly uh and uh which is which is perfect i've i've actually started with debuggers
uh like with like gdb i was just mostly debugging like low level stuff just like picking into the
memory not no extension no jeff no pawn pawn dbg or pawn bag whatever you want to call it no win dbg or
win bag whatever uh none of those i was just like using like pure like classic gdb for embedded
exploitation most of that and then i've and then i was just as i was like doing more like web app and
like dot net java i was like setting up php debuggers dot debuggers java debuggers and all of that and
then setting up a debugger helps a lot it is painful sometimes and that and people choose to move on i have
i have chose to move on sometimes but as i grew i've learned to don't move on and whatever it takes
just have it set up i kid you not uh in some of the pawn to own targets that we worked on there were some
like exotic architectures that they don't have they don't have it's called an artos like a real-time
operating system so it's not like a linux or whatever that you can get a shell and then you you
can upload the debugger or whatever right it's a real-time operating system and you need to like
when you want to debug stuff you gotta like open up the device and like attack some attack stuff sort
of like a physical device and all of that and just like it's pretty pretty painful and then when you go
through that you're like okay that takes like 10 hours how long it's gonna take me to like set up
this java debugger okay one hour two hour let's let's just do it right it works so so okay i'm sold i'm
sold you you sold me on the debugger thing that's great so so that but the next thing is kind of what
i want to ask about is like how does this work with various targets right because you're attacking
these iot devices you know you don't have access to the firmware specifically you know you don't
necessarily have access to this um you know docker container of the operating system or anything like
that um and you want to get one of these things set up uh how do you how do you get that set up and
then also you know in in a scenario where you're dealing with like a.net application or whatever
that has like um you know its own docker image or something like that uh how are you how are you
reaching into that docker image and setting up this debugger um versus like something in
in the iot world where you've got like a physical device that you don't have an image for
uh yeah uh okay i think uh i think i understand the question uh please please try to jump in if it wasn't
the right answer or if you felt like this is not the answer to your question uh most of the time i
don't know if it's like a java target if it's on a windows or a linux uh you need to understand how
the job of java process is being started and then you can like provide arguments to that to that command
that's starting the java process and then when you provide arguments to it you can you can enable
like java debug wire protocol like jdw or like other stuff to to enable debugging which exposes a
debugging service that you can connect to with your debugger most debuggers allow remote debugging
so that's what job so so for java let me just let me just echo this back to you so i can make sure
that i understand it yeah you know for java let's say we've got a docker container it spins up this java
app or whatever with the jar file you find whatever like .sh file or whatever that's being run that
triggers that java command you know java dash jar whatever right and then you you modify that file
usually and and you say okay um now i'm going to turn on debugging and then maybe you got to open
the port in in docker or whatever and then and then you can connect to that debugging port uh via your
debugger and it will allow you to just jump exactly and control that that flow of the application
yeah exactly uh yeah um you got it right you have this docker image you will try to get a shell on the
docker image modified in some sort of a way to to enable like some sort of arguments to the to the to the
to the java starter command or whatever bachelor script whatever it is in order to allow to enable
debugging that's what java usually that's the trick right there are some special cases too but
usually that's the way to do it uh as far as my knowledge goes um can you hear me right yes yeah
absolutely so so so for for like something like dot net um yeah you know i imagine it's a little
different are you like loading up a a dll or something like that or or how are you addressing that
yeah so with dotnet you just like uh you have different kind of debuggers uh but like with
dnspy usually what happens is is you use dnspy to dance but has like a debugger debugger feature you can
you can attach to processes or launch a process when you launch a process you can start immediately
debugging from the program start when you attach to a process you attach to its current state whatever
it is at the time that you're attaching to um attaching to it and then you you attach to it and
then you kind of start debugging but sometimes when you start to start debugging that target process
in dotnet you start seeing okay my break points are not even hit so you need to do that up the
optimization trick that i told you about that you just place an ini file next to it with some sort
of a value and then you just restart the process and then you attach it again um there are some
special cases too but these are the usual things that happen with iot stuff like embedded stuff most of
most of the times if it's if it's a device which is like linux space has like an operating system or
whatever um you you want to like push gdb to the device so you have like a statically compiled gdb
client or a gdb server you push it to the device you upload it in some sort of a way
we're taking uh considering you already gained a shell on the device because with iot stuff when you get
the device first you need to acquire an initial shell on the device um so let me ask you about
that process really quickly so so yeah um i also want to go back to the dot net thing for a second
because i would like to ask about um remote debugging with dot net because in in the scenario that you that
you had um you know we're in the same environment we can just attach to the process or whatever but if
we're doing like let's say we're running this internet application in like uh you know a different
environment is there some way to connect from like a from like a a remote context for that
as far as i know this is as far as my knowledge goes i don't know if it's possible to debug it dot
net process remotely with java it exposes a port that you can connect to it remotely uh so basically
it runs a listener but with dot net as far as i know the inspire attaches to the process and uses
windows debugging apis and mscorelib which is microsoft like microsoft library for dot that like
clr as in the common language runtime these are like dot specific technologies and engines and uses those
to debug into that process to attach to that process to debug it um but i don't i haven't heard about
somebody debugging the dotnet process remotely yeah that makes sense okay so so moving moving to the iot
side then when you're approaching this hardware target for like an event or whatever obviously you
got to get this initial shell to get you know your your debugger set up and on it right so um i feel
like there's only two approaches to this there's like hardware hacking techniques right where you've
got your ur you've got your j tag you've got um you know glitching related stuff that sort of thing um
or you got to go black box and you gotta you know you gotta try to pop it without actually uh you know
having the source code or whatever i guess there's one third option as well which is like if you can get
your hand on the firmware then you can sort of be white box but still not have a debugger
um what is your go-to flow with that and how do you address all of these three possibilities
yeah that's a great question uh so in order to like start researching like a iot device uh basically
first you need to like get the device after you got the device you want to interface with the device
right you want to get a shell on it assuming it's a linux based system not some sort of rtos or whatever
and then you can use like some sort of like a urt jtag whatever to interface with the device once you
do interface with the device if it has like some sort of a console you try to like usually after the
console you have you have unlimited shell like you have like a root shell or whatever and you want to
buy you want to get around it basically what i'm what i'm answering is the usual answer right it there
can be there can be different scenarios special cases as well which happen often uh but um in order to
bypass that kind of like a console either you get the password or you can get the password or whatever
sometimes the password has been public by someone else or whatever it's like a maybe like a root one
two three or a vendor name or whatever and then if you can't get around it then you can like use
glitching sometimes glitching helps almost all the time glitching works glitching is super powerful
if you master it like the sky's the limit and then you can like use like glitching to get around that
protected shell um if you do that's one way sometimes the firmware is available on the vendor
website you can just get the firmware back to the firmware and install the firmware on the device and
just get the shell that's it right sometimes it can happen uh sometimes you just gotta like yolo it
and then you're like okay i've i've i just take the chip off and then just read the chip and then
write to the chip backdoor the firmware whatever repack it repack it and then just put the put the chip
back but you need to like no disorder like soldering soldering like all that um and sometimes the chip
on the device is not like a like a like a like a simple normal flash chip or whatever it's like an
emmc or a bga which you usually see them in phones so when you like the solder or like take it out um
you you need to know how to do reballing yeah which is hard right exactly you gotta have like steady
hands and like do a clean job uh sometimes there is some sort of wiggle room for you to like mess up
just a bit you don't need to you don't need to be perfect in doing it but sometimes it which i've
did actually for pontoon 2024 uh pontoon japan i i had to there we were targeting these infotainment
systems uh which are like refotainment for cars and then most of the times you couldn't actually find
like you had to like desolder it at least for me yeah like for a lot of them i had to desolder them and
then uh the device is so expensive like i don't know two grand three grand four grand you can't
just buy two or whatever uh so you need to like desolder it and you need to do no reballing to put
the cheap chip back and then to to use your shell or whatever to go on the device and start working on
it but the sky's the limit uh as i said sometimes and then maybe maybe maybe sometimes even you don't
need to make it more difficult maybe sometimes black box you can find a command injection in the
application and just get it with shell that's it right uh so so maybe maybe try to go with the
easier approaches um is is so man that's that's a two grand device i know that that i've only had one
or two experiences you know hacking an iot device where i actually have to like pull the chip off get
it read pull the firmware that sort of thing but in the first time i did it you know i i was literally
like i was shaking you know and this is like a 60 device that they gave me for free you know like
and and so are you do you guys have to buy your own devices for these competitions or are they like
pumping you for the devices at all afterwards if you find a valid bug
uh no usually with 99 of the targets you need to buy them yourself and then and then sometimes
sometimes the device is only available in you like us and like you're like another like continent or
something and then and then they like the device is only sold in us so uh goes to your imagination
the system to even get your hands on the device how difficult it is to to get the product to you and
yeah um it it gets it gets difficult but but uh worth mentioning for like targets like tesla
right so you want to target tesla right if you're a well-known researcher or you have done tesla
exploits before for zero day initiative point to own competition uh point to own will provide you
with not a car they don't they don't they don't say all right extra incentive here
yeah not not not the car but they will uh send you the the the correct acus that you need
the the the computer in the car did the issues that you need that that are part of the attack surface
that are accepted uh so you need to like wire the issues and whatever and make sure when you like
plug in it plug it into your outlet you don't burn the ac or whatever uh then you can you can
like set it up and then just like start finding bugs on it but you need like that's not for someone
who who just wants to come to point to on like the first day and then they will give them like
issues or whatever give him or her whatever uh it depends on that kind of like relationship that you
have with the organizers and tesla knows you and all of that kind of stuff that's that's yeah that's
crazy man yeah yeah that's that's nuts and i i want to ask so you know this is a high risk environment
for you you're buying these these these and you know these things i know that i burned through four
chips i think the first time i was trying to pull pull a chip out you know just just from lack of
experience and i and i i did better afterwards you know i bought i think like 10 of the devices or
whatever and i was able to finally get it uh consistently but um you know when you're going
into it it's a it's a pretty high investment environment um so how how much of the time would
you say that you're dealing with um i can just connect to you art or jtag and get a shell versus
i have to pull the firmware via you know pulling the chip and the emmc chip and and getting it into a
reader and getting it to read um versus like a black box a black box approach versus like firmware like
what is the distribution of those four what is most common and what is least common
uh let me let me think how how to you're asking pretty solid questions uh that's why that's why
you're getting me hooked on it um yeah so basically like in the first like i think in the first like
12 hours or 10 hours i'll kind of like exhaust all the possibilities that i can get a shell except the
black box kind of thing like into like first eight or 10 hours i'll i'll exhaust all the hardware
related kind of techniques that i that i am aware of that i can maybe launch against this target um
10 hour is it enough isn't it enough i don't know it's just it's just the way that i do it
um and then after if i don't get a shell in that like 10 hours or or i conclude that okay after this
10 hours i've i've exhausted all the simple tricks that i could do now it doesn't work in the 10 hours
either i'm gonna go black box or maybe maybe if i could maybe if i would have gone with black box i
would have found it in the first five minutes who knows you don't know that that's just me and then
or i would be like okay i will invest more time on glitching it at the right time because because you
might say why don't you always just take the chip off because sometimes the chip is encrypted and then the
keys are like they are stored somewhere else or like you need to talk to this like the system on
chip soc or whatever yeah yeah uh like or in or it's in an enclave or something um and it's not as
easy as that so uh some sometimes i'm kind of like in the first 10 hours i'll conclude either i want to
go fault fault injection fully or i just want to like be like okay i can't do anything i just got a
black box it somehow and then find a way in what's your what's your kind of like what's your intuition
on the order like of of how often these work so to like you know 50 of the time you are gives me a
shell or like you know what's your intuition on like how often these various techniques work
the most often way that i use i just use you art uh if i just use you art and then i combine it with
glitching and then you get a shell you definitely get a shell at least for for me this is this from
i don't represent like all the people who have done this kind of research this is just this my answer
uh for me i just combine like i just connect with you art sometimes you have a shell which you don't
see it often happening i just want to own targets anymore uh they're like high value targets uh so
so so they've been well tested kind of uh this the easy the easy doors have been closed and then i just
combine it with like glitching and then uh most of the times they don't have any protection against
glitching and then i just that that that's my way in uh that's my usual go-to and then if that doesn't
work uh i'll go for the chip if that doesn't work uh black box okay gotcha wow that's that's uh
that's pretty cool so so a lot of times you know i think it might be worthwhile for me to invest a
little bit into understanding how glitching works a little bit a little bit better glitching and
fault injection because um yeah once you go that route with the when you're pulling the chip off
it's i've never soldered a chip back on successfully you know and gotten it to read um that's very hard
to do um and and i think you need some more advanced equipment than what i've got as well i've
just got a you know beginner's hardware hacking setup here with like my hot air gun and and uh you
know a ton of flux and that sort of thing so um that that's really interesting to hear that that
fault injection um and that sort of thing is is a more common approach for you to get through there
um okay cool so now you know we've gone through that path we've got a shell on this device um
what are now now we're getting a debugger set up live on that that actual device so you're kind of
looking through the file system you're you're trying to figure out what is starting the you know web
interface or the whatever tcp interface or whatever and then you're hooking into that is that is that
the idea yeah so once you have a shell now hopefully you'll start like understanding what's available
as the attack surface right the goal is getting remote code execution without user interaction on
this device and one other thing that you need to you need to consider is sometimes you need to you
sometimes pontone says for example these kind of services are out of question right we don't want
if an exploit is impacting these we don't want it even though even though you're you are achieving
remote code execution but if it's targeting this service we don't want it uh because these some
this is this has kind of like recently came up in pontoon in the in the last in the last few years
you wouldn't be dealing with it as much as it might sound but uh it can happen that for example
if they say i don't know if this uh routers on this router any any exploit on the upmp service
universal plug and play we don't want it because upnps are in these targets are not made by the vendor
they're made by the third party even though even though you might come and say okay doesn't matter
yes the vendor the the the client is using it right but but for some reason they they they have their
own reasons right and they're the organizers so it's their rules it's their their game right they
say like we don't want it right they have their own reasons and then so you might not want to be
looking at it but basically you find services uh you exclude the ones that should be excluded and then
you start working on them to see if you can trigger anything remotely basically what's what are the open
ports uh sending a packet to each port what does it do what does it trigger what service does it work
with detect service we try to uh is it decompilable do you compile it disassemble it whatever you set up
a debugger you you attach to it you start analyzing all what's available you find for danger you look for
dangerous behaviors you do you utilize your static analysis you set up a fuzzer it can be a black box
fuzzer a dumb fuzzer you kind of like develop your intuition on making a bit a faster and better fuzzer
you make like a snapshot based fuzzing with like emulation you make a grammar for your fuzzer you make
it better and better to like start harvesting memory corruption vulnerabilities and when i said that i said
the sentence maybe like in one or two minute two minutes but having like emulation set up in your local
server or like in your remote server to fuzz the same binary that was so so you have this target which
has like i don't know one gig of ram yeah or whatever two gigs of ram or maybe like megabytes
right yeah you have this device and you want to take which has its own tool chain which has its own
like operating systems or whatever everything like that architecture everything right everything like
and it's not like using the word saying i mean everything on it is living in a harmony together it's
just some sort of a glued together which is like some sort of abomination that they've managed to like
just make it work and then you just want to take like one piece of that abomination and put it on
the latest linux version on your server of course it's not going to work right of course yeah but
it never happens you need to yeah it never usually never happens so you need to set up like your own
like emulation with like kimu or whatever you want to use unicorn kimu chilling whatever it is
all the framework okay hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on so you just so i've heard i've
heard of uh kimu right q emu but what were the other ones you mentioned yeah unicorn it's a unicorn engine
unicorn engine some simple same thing for for emulation the other one it's it's written killing
which is q i l i n g okay but but as far as i know the author of the author of it the guy who wrote it
says chilling so i'm saying chilling as well okay but it's killing whatever yeah okay i see it it's also
it's a it's a wraparound unicorn engine which you can utilize to to write emulation and even a snapshot
based fuzzing okay but but the most powerful one that i recommend people to go after is using things
like just like being able to like use like afl with the combination of key kemo if you can like
slap those together and then make it work live afl is a is a pretty powerful it's a pretty pretty
pretty powerful library written in rust so you gotta know how to record in rust that that kind of like
that's that's kind of like a shortstopper to a lot of people but uh it's definitely recommended to
to to be able to do it okay as far as you can yeah if you can get kim and afl working that that's
that that's a decent option there are better options too why not but that's good enough yeah
that makes a lot of sense okay modern knowledge goes so so i'm i'm diving into your whole flow here okay
i'm i'm i'm breaking apart the whole the whole brain so we we we get a hold of a shell somehow
likely by hardware hacking but potentially you know via dumping the firmware and then finding a bug with
just just code review and then popping it and then getting a shell then we're taking all the binaries
taking all the different pieces of the environment decompiling it if we can whatever we're getting
our disassembler exactly um uh this is exactly and then we go keemu and then we go um or any of these
other uh emulation softwares to get the correct environment get the correct um uh you know libraries
or whatever in you don't have to but for for for fuzzing or like having your local setup for like
because because you so why do you do it i i said before you want to fuzz this abomination but it's
running on a device which is too slow right so if you want to blast it with like a million requests
either it's gonna just like die or reboot or whatever yeah so if you manage to take it out and put it on a
on your own machine which has like 128 giga of ram or like i don't know a ton of cores and it's like fast
uh all that you can just like because uh i don't i'm gonna say this you're an expert obviously but
i'm gonna say this for for for people who don't know right so you have this binary which is a uh
i don't know uh imagine imagine this this device is a smart speaker right this smart speaker understands
parsing mp3 files right and the way it works is the web server will receive an mp3 file and then will
somehow pass this mp3 file to this executable right yeah you wanna you wanna fuzz this mp3 parser you
wanna you wanna because you know maybe you can find a memory corruption on this mp3 parser so you can
find a memory corruption on the speaker and get code execution that way right ah i see either you can go
by uploading mp3 files to the web server which the web server needs to process your http request
take the mp3 file save the mp3 file pass the mp3 file to the mp3 parser mp3 parser goes to the
initialization phase to come up as a process to allocate some memory load its libraries and all of
that basically an active process and then opening it opens the file reads the file start parsing it
you went through i don't know nine steps to get to the parsing but with snapshot based fuzzin you can
eliminate all of those eight steps take the file and wrote a snapshot snapshot based fuzzin it it's
it's said it can easily be set but it's not easily done you can set up your snapshot base fuzzin to tell
your snapshot base fuzzin to if if if this is the function which is uh at this again this is a compiled
binary it's not source code right this is compiled right if if at this function in this in this binary this
offsets in memory right if this function this sub routine starts and it starts parsing this mp3 file
and it ends here and just this a thousand other functions before and after it we just want to
fuzz this so i want you to con to to change the flow of execution to here and go until here and then and
then when it reaches end here you go back and then you revert the snapshot revert the state of the memory
to what it was right because you you you got to understand either you're fuzzing a stateless or a
stateful kind of like function uh maybe because maybe because uh maybe when you're fuzzing this
like a subroutine whatever maybe it changes something global if this is what you want to fuzz maybe it
changes something above it right above it outside of your area and then if if that thing changes a lot
it causes a crash which doesn't happen normally it only happens in your local testing environment right
now i'm getting too technical but no no no no this is exactly what we need to know so for these
snapshot fuzzers you're isolating a specific block of this you know exactly piled code right so you're
doing this you know looking at assembly and you're just essentially priming the environment that this
is is run in with the memory offsets etc and you're just running it over and over and over again with
different inputs to see what's triggering the the the breakage and now i want to ask you this okay
because my intuition as a web hacker would be shell the device get the source code look at the web
interfaces or or any of the external facing um services right that that would be my first thing
whereas it seems to me that you use the external interfaces like okay this web interface and then
you just skipped over the web interface and you're like and the web interface calls this binary with
the mp3 and now i'm going to grab this binary and fuzz the heck out of it is that because you are more
interested in fuzzing as a as a hacker like that's the thing that you're interested in right now or is that
because you've seen more success in this environment going after the lower level things the lower level
binaries that sort of thing um in these sort of abomination of a setup of an iot device right versus
going after the the web interface stuff yeah so um i've um i just want to build up on what you said
um the the more it depends on you but with pawn to own usually the more difficult your exploit is
the better chance it's not going to get duped so uh okay okay skipping escaping the web server i won't
skip it to be honest for the snap for writing the snapshot based fuzzer to implement the snapshot based
fuzzer idea i need to skip it but while it's while this okay the fuzzer is done now it's fuzzing i have
time now i can spend it on looking at the web server right and i do find it i do and then i
found the command injection in the first request of the login page what right obviously it's going
to be found by everyone and obviously it's going to be patched the last second so i shouldn't stop at
that i should find as many bugs as possible hoping that at least one of them will survive it is a cruel
kind of way to look at it but that's just a fact because i'm i'm ready until the last second of the
competition i'm ready my full chain is ready uh i have three bugs in my chain i'm i'm taking i'm
catching a flight i'm in i don't know vancouver toronto whatever right i arrive 10 minutes before
the competition the vendor pushes the over the air update just either either killing one of the bugs in
the change or killing all the killing all the bugs in the chain or even sometimes what happened to me
was they didn't kill any bugs they just added a feature or added even a string doesn't matter added
something to the binary that will shift the offset in a way that my exploit will fail right because my
exploit is like using some sort of i don't know like a rob chain and it's relying on some sort of offset
or something aligned at some place you must be furious so exactly right so that's why that's
kind of cool actually i feel like they should give you a version of the app like okay the the product
as it exists uh you know july 15th at 11 57 a.m you know like as it exists in that moment that is what
you're you're going up against but they don't do that they say the most current patch of the device and
they can patch the device in leading up to the competition day yeah wow is zdi aware of this like
i feel like zdi would like because for for hacker one you know when we have this is a zdi rule
wow it is a zdi rule so for for hacker one when we have situations like this they they they intervene for
us they come in and they say hi i'll uh listen guys you know clearly justin had an rce here because
he just handed you your etsy password file um you know even though it's it got patched he shelled it
you know so you you still owe him a bounty right but but maybe that isn't the case in the zdi environment
no so all of these rules aren't made by the vendor right it's made by zdi and and the model is we want
to make this as real world as possible we're targeting real world software at real time we're not we're
not it it's it it's not a done deal with the vendor so the the targets that you'll see in zdi
they haven't accepted to be being pawned to on they haven't chose to be important they've been brought
to pawn to on zdi just puts up the targets uh the vendor doesn't have a saying that we want we want
this to be there or we don't want this to be there they can yeah they can take the initiative to to
approach cdi saying very interesting i didn't know that tested or whatever yeah they can take the
initiative to to approach cdi with putting something there but they can't take the initiative coming
saying oh we don't want our product to be tested it it's not their call to make and cdi will test it
zdi will take cdi will purchase the bug if if there is a bug and will immediately report it to the vendor
whether the vendor likes it or not so the video zdi wants to get the box fixed of whether the when
the uh wants or not so is there is there any meta strategy when it comes to this then because i imagine
the the people that are not actively involved in the competition right the person that doesn't have
a rep in the slack group or whatever they are probably going to be more um malicious towards the
hackers right where it's like okay we're looking at our logs we're determining okay somebody's got
a command injection over here so we're going to patch that you know now uh and pushing pushing
updates over versus the people that are actually in the slack or whatever or whatever you got however
you guys do it and interacting with the the people that are actively researching their products is there
so is there any strategy there do you want to go for the the there is no communication there is no
communication with the zero the only communication that you have with the zdi either so so you you'll so
this is how it works the researcher will uh you you see you see the targets you choose what you want
to work on you go work on it if you have questions you set it to zdi if you have any questions i is
this is this service out of the scope i have this question or assumption is it is this considered zero
click is this considered zero interaction whatever zdi will as fast as possible as missed as possible
will get back to you immediately answering your question uh and then whatever right you do that and
then you just find your bike write your export chain you show up at the competition you execute it and
done if it's done you immediately you and zdi employees employees will immediately like like two
seconds later you're sitting in a room talking to the vendor directly like like with like a webcam or
whatever right you're talking to the vendor directly and you're disclosing the bug to them
with zdi right that's crazy and you're getting the bug patched right so all the communications that you
have is with zdi if there is anything to be uh made sure of zdi will contact the vendor kind of on
behalf of you kind of wow um that's a very different world man just to give you some introspection into
the live hacking event um because we do want to kind of discuss the ponte own versus hacker one live
hacking events or flow here um you know when we get the invite for the live hacking event um there's a
scope call that happens and that scope call uh is actually the the person the target saying like
hey this is what we want you to attack this is what our bounties are here's what our bonuses are whatever
right and we're here to help whenever you have any questions right so then they spin up this slack group
and they're they've got employees in there they've got like channels where it's like hey you know if you
got any questions about the architecture if you have questions about like um you know are you seeing
this ssrf hitting your internal servers or whatever like that sort of thing they've got all that set up
and available for you to help the researcher as much as possible um find the bones within within their
system and and sometimes you know some of these machines are more responsive responsive than not you
know um and vice versa but um at the end of the day typically the program is on your side and they are
like trying to help you along the way as much as possible and they want to pay out as many bounties as
they can because um that means that their attack surface is getting more secured and they want to
uh you know they want to get budget to do these events again so that they can you know get more
more bounties and get more bugs submitted and get their attack surface more secure and that's very
different it seems from the pwn to own environment and i imagine a lot of that is because of the fact
that pwn to own competitions are not optional you know for the vendor it's it's not sure we're gonna hack
your shit and you have to allocate a resource to it yeah yeah that's crazy yeah exactly uh so you you
said something good right you said uh that would um the the vendor wants to spend the budget to make
stuff secure and everything yeah so it that thing that that kind of like the the goodwill right is in
point on as well but the vendor is not spending money it's it's zdi's budget was being spent on
making these products safer it's not like they're charging the vendor or they're getting money from
the vendor or the vendor is providing budget to them no they can do a sponsorship like google as
google is is nice enough to show up and sponsor uh sometimes i don't know samsung i think i don't
think samsung is like synology i'm sure they did synology is another company um that's like a network
equipment routers and stuff yeah like synology has sponsored google and i think tesla as well
they can sponsor but i don't know if it's like a lexmark printer or a tp link router tp link is not
paying any money or like like or other someone else as far as as far as i know uh they're not paying
any money and the zdi is spending the budget and uh one might ask then why is it i'm doing such a thing
like uh is it just doing exactly what's the incentive that's it the goodwill right so uh zdi is a
organization a part of trend micro right so it's called trend micro zero day initiative and then uh
brian gorans uh who is the director of the uh zero day initiative uh and which like basically manages
zero day initiative uh what what he does is so uh we have uh they make a product at uh train micro does
at that zero day initiative work with trend micro they can make a product um i've uh i think i've uh i
i forgot the product name but i can find it uh they make a product uh i think it's called tipping point
if i'm not wrong tipping point is a is intrusion detection system that uh trend micro makes that has
actual zero day protection i'm not i'm not talking about jokes i'm not talking about just saying that
you have zero day protection or whatever you you have so they have immediately what when when they
purchase the box from point to immediately minutes later the signatures are ready pushed to the device
and ready to defend against that attack and that's that's their gold as far as i know that's the golden
product kind of that's called tipping point that is being sold to like uh like high value organizations
and important customers uh and it's very crucial and then that's that that's the way that this whole
thing goes and zero the initiative is also uh interested in the techniques that the researchers
use because the rupturing the time make is different than the rupturing the other guy makes
and maybe in my rupturing i use the technique which is not that well known and that's interesting to zero
day zero the initiative researchers to kind of learn that knowledge and apply it to different kind of
targets and stuff so you're selling your exploit and your research knowledge both at the same time you
said and your exploit is being you mentioned before that that when you i think this was off air but um
that when you submit a bug you have to submit a white paper along with that bug describing the
vulnerability right exactly so so yeah the techniques you're participating remotely documented
yeah yes so so at the end you need to provide a white paper and your exploit fully and you need to
explain your explain your exploit and your white paper sorry for the bad english but you need to
explain both of them uh to the uh to the zero day initiative researchers uh and sometimes the vendor
as well but it all gets done in exactly the same day when you're to do the exploit it's not there is
there is nothing going back and forth with with zero day initiative researchers they're beasts like they
even if you don't explain anything they understand it like they're wow i can't emphasize how talented they are
i think one of the most talented researchers that exist vulnerability researchers like i'm not saying
they're the only one but they are truly one of the ones that are truly talented and they work there and
then they can understand your exploit like like a cake like it's easy to them and that's amazing yeah
so you need to at the end provide the white paper with your whole walkthrough of what you did why you
did it how does it work everything okay gotcha wow that that's great so so yeah very there are some
differences between these two competitions here and that's what i kind of want to go through now you
know and continue going through that so so there's no there's no interaction sort of before the actual
event with the actual team besides getting the scope and and that comes from zdi and then um so how much
time do you normally have before the the event occurs so they release okay here are the targets
here's the scope or whatever how much time before you're on-site demoing your your exploit and what
does that pre-event look like so two to three months is usually what you have okay um if i'm not
miscalculating stuff um which i'm really bad at with i'm really bad with dates and stuff um time frames but
i think it's like almost kind of like around something near two months to three months uh that
that's the kind of time frame before the competition uh deadline reaches and then you're at the stage and
you're launching your exploits or whatever if you're participating remotely and if you find a bug and you
want to apply to attend the competition and you participate remotely you will send your white paper
and your uh exploit uh to the uh to the vendor to inside the to not not the vendor to do their
initiative yeah to zdi yeah and then they they take it and then they make sure like you're legit because
you're you're coming remotely you can be like an imposter or whatever yeah so because they're
allocating time uh but if you come in person then you're good uh uh you can just show you can just
provide just just just enough details and then you show up and you launch your exploit how far in advance
do you have to register for that like is that you know like you can do that up to like two weeks before
the competition or when do you register it's it's usually up to one week before the competition wow okay
and and do they sponsor travel for people that have you know that are coming in person or is it sometimes
some sometimes this is sometimes they try to sometimes they they they pay for the travel uh and
the way that they do it is um they say that if you're a previous pontoon winner winner doesn't mean
number one winner so pontoon calls a win when you have a successful exploit uh you if you can pull off a
successful exploit on this stage and there is no dupe with anyone they call it a full win that's a
full way that's if you can be the number one at the competition then you're the master of pawn so those
are different things if you manage to have a successful attempt with no dupe with anyone
previously at pontoon like the the the competition before before the one that is going to be happening
uh they say okay as a token of appreciation for you putting the time in others again will uh give you
this amount of this amount of money to to support you to come to the competition again wow very cool
so so this is a similar system a bit to to hacker one which is um there are two types of invites there's
um like the first tier invites i i guess and then there's like second tier invites these second tier
invites are normally the result of a first tier invitee um plus one in you yeah so the anyone who gets
a first tier invite gets their their travel sponsored uh their hotel and their flight and that sort
of thing and that doesn't necessarily mean they've performed well at a live hacking event before it
just means that they have performed well on the hacker one platform or against this target and were
selected for for this competition and then the tier one invites can say all right i'd like to also take
uh you know cena with me on this trip right and then they send they select you if they select
you from the plus one list then you get an invite as well but you have to sponsor your own travel
um that's cool and so uh there's that sort of setup which i think is really cool the the difference
between man uh see the listen listen point to own it's like mortal combat right it's like it's you
go there you gotta fight for the last breath right you don't have you don't have um it is professional
it is professional yeah as much as possible as as i could think of right but um let me say it's harder
yeah it's harder to pull off yeah i think i think maybe maybe maybe that that's the right word in my
vocabulary to to put it to put it together it's harder right you don't have you don't have like
that kind of a grace period saying on this specific version or whatever right right it's harder because
they're they're trying to say that what we do is is targeting real world at the real time the second that
their exploit is being run right the guy shows up at the competition exploits safari chrome firefox edge
the same day in the latest version and and you can't disable over the air update on a browser right
it's just it's getting the update right at exactly the same second you just exposed all of them it
that's like elite as it gets as far as i know yeah no it's insane and it makes it makes sense too why
you need more time because for these for these hacker one competitions we we are attacking production
environments as well and they can submit patches and stuff like that and sometimes that does happen
um but uh you know these are these are hardened bug bounty apps that have been running a program for
for a long time um but the time frame is also much shorter uh for us it's only like 10 to 14 days
between when you get the target to when you are standing there working you know in the environment so i
think one thing that's a little bit tricky about this is in the hacker one live hacking events you
don't have as much time to to craft these sort of um masterpieces of exploits and there are still
people that do it for example shubs almost every event that he goes to shubs from the asset note team
um almost every single time he has like a pawn to own crazy he's a crazy guy he is he almost has a
point to own you know level chain rce at every single event you know that that we go to i mean
it's just it's mind boggling and he does that in 10 to 14 days you know um from scratch he he he's he's
one of a kind like yeah it is like he's he's one of a kind and uh what he does is is truly like remarkable
yeah i totally agree and and i think so yeah there's definitely this aspect of like if you're looking to
be um if you're looking for an environment of more collaboration and stuff like that with with the
team but also i think with your with your um your fellow competitors um hacker one has a lot of uh
places for that and accommodations for that what does it look like to collaborate with a team in a
ponto on environment uh with point on usually uh um you need to you need to understand that um the money
that you're going after uh has a lot of has a lot of conditions that you need to be you need to be
careful about if a target yeah if a target uh has been put up on zdi on the on the reward list if you
read the rules carefully it says like 50 000 for this target but it's 50 000 for the first win what
does that mean exactly imagine uh person a and person b and person c go to the competition and they
want to hack this target if person a goes first they do a random draw right they randomly put the
put the names of people in like a hat or some sort of a wheel they they uh i don't know spin it and
then they take out the names and then um let's say the order goes to i don't know a b and c three three
guys right three people or whoever uh and then and then and then they go on and then the person a
managed to manages to exploit the device successfully since he's the first guy or she is the first guy
they get full money for that device they get the 50 000 then person b goes person b can have three
outcomes kind of three or four outcomes i'll go over first they can have a unique book or completely
unique blockchain they if they do it and they they finish the exploit so a full win is called they get
25 000 they get they don't get the 50 000 they get 25. wait wait wait even if it's a totally unique bug
just against that even if it's a totally only 25 not the 50. yeah they get 25. oh no they only get 25.
only the first person so so you need the factor of luck that's what yeah but uh i'll go over more
detail now so but the person now let's say the first person b goes and they're full way in 25 000.
the person c goes if it's a if it's a full but if it's completely new bugs like so if they manage to
find bugs that the person a didn't find person b didn't find and the person c is so special it's 25 000
again but if it is a duplicate with those two other guys doesn't matter which one of them they get half
of the half so they get half of the 25 000 so 12.5 right exactly yeah they get 12.5 that that's the
money they get wow that's very different but there are some wiggle rooms and some additional ideas to
put out there so each time for a target you have two things you have monetary reward and master of pawn
points uh so a target is 50 000 it also has five master of points master of pawn points uh so uh
i just call them points now because there's a lot of peace and i'll mess up the sentence yeah so uh
let's say it has five points and uh 50 000 whatever if person a goes they get the five points person b goes
it's a unique bug but they're the second person so they get 25 000 but they do get the five points and
so if if if they work so hard to manage to find a lot of bugs but they weren't so lucky to go first
they still might be able to be the master of pawn at the end day uh because the end day they count the
points whomever has the highest points they get to get to be master of pawn they'll get recognition
uh some sort of a trophy and some additional money good money uh really good money and um and uh oh so
there's some wiggle room here as well right so imagine your person c right you're nervous you go on
you're like okay uh first person a and b when and then this has got to be a dupe right but for some reason
uh the it says uh i don't know is this right there's like there's many ways to salvation or whatever
yeah yeah there are many ways to to do something right right so maybe for a bug maybe for a bug that
you managed to exploit you only needed to chain two bugs maybe if i do it i need to manage four things
why it depends uh but i will go through an example with you to to make it more established right but
imagine you went on your your your rc exploit consists of two bucks an information disclosure
and maybe a arbitrary file upload whatever right maybe you needed to disclose the file system path in
order to be able to write to a specific directory right so you needed and the default path is random so
you needed to disclose it whatever right so you need to change these two things together so your
final x root consists of two bucks right but imagine person person tree goes right uh so and so these two
bugs were for person tree right person c right let's call it but person a managed to i don't know use only
one bug to get the rc right they didn't need the information disclosure right when person c goes
uh since they have two bucks and it's an additional book that the person a didn't have so it's like a
partial dude that adds to your money that it's a partial dupe exactly it's a partial dupe so it adds to
your money it's based on some sort of a percentage but it's not half of the half anymore it's like some
sort of a one-third or like i don't know okay interesting interesting so more complex chains or or
chains that have more components to them get rewarded further the more complex that you can make it
the better it is okay so there's so much that's kind of the way to look at it insanely different
from the live hacking events because so much rules because so much rules in the hacker one live hacking
events you only get a dupe if it's literally the exact same bug you know i mean or if it's on the same
endpoint or whatever right um so if i get an rce via you know um you know pseudo random number generator
plus a file upload right something like that and you get an rce via sql injection to file right to
you know that sort of thing in a different endpoint both of those get the full bounty
um however if you if you know multiple people submit the same thing then the the same prize for that
that critical bug or whatever starts getting split you know in half in thirds and fourths right
um so that's that's very different and actually the way that that zdi does it um is very for a second
i thought it was it was better for the researcher because it gets it gets halfed and then halfed but
it's actually the that target in general right so once the first person claims the first 50k prize or
whatever for that target the most that the the researcher b and researcher c are competing for is
25 grand is that accurate exactly oh my gosh you got it right no man so it's so much last for that draw is
worth 25 grand so much luck so many factors i told you it's like this is hard i told you it's yeah
yeah uh it is and a lot of things you need to like the vendor doesn't push a patch you're lucky your
exploit doesn't fail you can finish it and you have three attempts and each attempt is five minutes so you
need to be careful with your everything you need to i've i've kind of wrote down like the steps that you
need to go through for a target i can read it for you right just like it quickly yeah so basically
with a target uh before before i read this uh i've i've a lot of this is based on another talk that
alex plaskett alex plaskett is a phenomenal security researcher let me write that down who works at ncc group
alex plaskett uh if i'm not pronouncing him pronouncing his name right wrong he's a phenomenal
security researcher he's he's crazy how good he is he's been exploiting everything that you can think
of from the back in the ancient time until now and way more i'm sure in the future uh he's a good friend
of mine and then he has given another kind of like an interview talk about pontoon uh with a uh in
another youtube channel or something that i forgot the name for i apologize for it uh this is my bad i
maybe i'll give it a link you put it down there or like put it in a link or something uh so people can
go it's a it's a great youtube channel a great interviewer and great interviewee i think i don't
know yeah that's right great people in general right um so alex has kind of like put together like a
uh kind of like a less methodology of how how things go go uh together yeah when looking at these
targets and i'm trying to like replicate the same thing that he said so basically uh because i i
exactly do his method and then once he so i sorry uh no you're good i should have actually told you
before the podcast to get some some water or something like that because you you see let me get
some water during this whole thing i've been like drinking my coffee or whatever do you have water nearby
or you got to go grab it yeah let me go grab it go grab it take a second hey guys real quick i just
wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team they have been absolutely killing it the past couple
months taking the content from the podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media
posts whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever they've been rocking it so i just wanted to give them
a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts of cyber security content as well as social media
management they do technical blogs they do comprehensive social media management
so if your organization could benefit from any of those types of services make sure you head over
to hackercontent.com drop them a line and mention the podcast when you do to get your first month of
cyber security content marketing services for free all right that's it let's get back to the pod
all right all right all right so we're gonna let this man get some water really quick okay so tell us
about this the steps for pontone yeah so there's steps for pontone inspired by alex blaskett uh what it says is
basically you first you do background research right you have this target that they announced for
pontone i don't know it's it's i don't know router a smart speaker whatever you do a background research
right you look for you start searching for the product to see if there were any previous vulnerabilities
previous write-ups previous ways to get an initial shell all of that could be important and valuable to
you previous reverse engineerings and mitigation bypasses and stuff you learn all of that right
so it's better to build up on other researchers that are out there instead of starting from scratch so
sometimes you need to so because only some of the targets from pontone may may god repeat may get
repeated right right not all of them right so it's always best to do some background research uh go
through the uh previous vulnerabilities and all of that and then after that i'm just reading reading
through it uh then you need to get the device get a shell on it basically some sort of a way to debug it
and all that uh to research it to put it in a like a lab environment and then you start after you've got
a shell or whatever you start uh mapping the attack surfaces what's available what can be exploited
what's important what's excluded all that after that you start doing reverse engineering static
analysis code review whatever it is fuzzing basically looking for bugs and sometimes you need to as you
go for different kind of targets sometimes you need to make your make your own tools for that target
maybe there is some sort of a tedious task maybe maybe there is some sort of a condition with this
target that you need to make a tool for so you need to be do you need to be fast agile about it
uh like writing plugins for i don't know like your favorite disassembler that is gydra either whatever
uh write something about it uh for it uh and then you have uh the after you i don't know found the
bug through fuzzing code review dynamic static whatever you did kind of magic then you get to exploit
development where you make your poc and then one thing that is really important is making your exploit as
efficient as possible as reliable as possible and as portable as possible because the day of the competition
the poc gods will with you the way that you can think of
your your your your cable goes missing or your cable who that you were using for five years without any problem
starts don't not working or this device doesn't work or the battery keeps dying or the system gets
giving you a blue screen or a kernel panic or whatever i don't know like or like you're like uh
usbc hub doesn't work or the the libraries the libraries that are importing your exploit don't work
and then okay you need to okay this happens now you need to move your exploit to a different machine
maybe zdi gives you a new laptop saying okay launch through launch from this laptop so you need to have
your exploits ready uh even even your laptop got i don't know burned or crashed or exploded sure you
have the exploit somewhere else that you can get it uh somewhere secure hopefully and then uh you can put
put it quickly on another machine with no setup previously and the exploit can be launched quickly
without problem and you need to be able to write your exploit as beautiful as possible because this
happened to me right so um one time that i was doing the competition uh at a certain point um i've got
my exploit ready it was like a full chain it was a memory corruption when i read the and it was relying
on a rob chain that uh was like pulling off a rob chain and when i uh when i caught my flight and then
uh landed in uh toronto in canada and i went to the competition and i said it was my turn to to exploit
the device um one of the devices uh when it got to my turn i realized that the vendor had just patched
as just pushed the patch uh it wasn't even a security patch it was just like a feature patch and i think
they did that purposely to because they knew there might be like memory corruptions it's not really far
fished for a vendor to think that and then they pushed like a feature patch that was just adding
some sort of a string or something uh that would just like cause the the main executable on that
device to have like different offsets and then that kind of like uh that kind of led into my rupture not
working properly but since i knew uh from hearing out past experiences from other people at the competition
that it's best to make a exploit like refine and like make a clean exploit that would be portable and
would be easily modifiable on stage at that moment when when it's your turn it you've already had a
failed attempt and you have a couple of minutes to complete it and you've put months of work uh to
to get something out of it it's like it's like an investment and then you don't want things to go
wrong so you need to like keep it together and then do the changes which i would and especially like
shout out to zdi when you're at the stage when you're on stage and you're you're doing your
exploitation they're super they're super uh like calm and trying to help and try to even they ask you
like what do you need what's wrong can we do anything tell us the problem maybe we can do something maybe we
can maybe we can change something like they always try to like come up with a way to to help you they
they love to buy the bugs they love to pay pay the researchers because they know it's so much work
and uh that that's that's what really good that's what's really good about them and then
long story short since the exploit was was well written uh this i can kind of say i i managed to
change what i needed to change without breaking a lot of parts in the exploit which was exploiting a race
condition and a memory corruption at the same time wow and then got it working and then it landed on
the second attempt i think uh and i was super happy uh uh and then i got it through and then that was a
lesson to me the relief in that moment must be crazy and and um yeah well props to you for building out
a cool exploit and i i do have a similar story to this where um you know we only have two weeks before
the live hacking events to actually do any of this stuff so this one time i was really working hard on a
hardware device and i was going down this rabbit hole and i knew that it was possible to uh get a
very impactful i'll just say you know we were able to take over this whole device and look through the
camera and look through the microphone right um and listen to the microphone remotely and um and i was
like i i was like i know that this is possible but we didn't have enough time and i popped it less
than an hour before the end of the pop the competition you know in that period up to that last
hour and and the whole team was sitting behind me and i like showed it and they're like yeah you got
it and i was like wow yes you know like it's just the best feeling ever so i think there's a lot of
stress that comes the best feeling you know but there's also a lot of payoff right yeah yeah exactly
uh it it it it has it has a really good payoff right as i said earlier right at the beginning
uh i didn't know at at some point that even there there's going to be jobs for it or there is a job
for it uh it's just the feeling the excitement right uh of course i'm working for money right uh just like
nowadays but when i started it was just like the only purpose was was the feeling and the feeling only
and the excitement like i i can't find it in anything else personally personally i didn't
find it in anything else so far yeah no that's amazing man okay so so you said you know in this
list from alex um you know you've got create a a very high integrity um easily portable you know you've
got all the um libraries and stuff you need packaged together you've got all of your office sets in
variables rather than just like you know add it into strings or whatever right so for easy
modification you got your exploit ready to go what's the next step in the process yeah yeah so uh
as i said i went through a lot of steps but uh after the after you know like your exploits like
proper and then uh it's easily portable you just one other thing that these might sound the same thing but
even though they kind of like collide but testing your exploit again and again and again i'm not gonna
lie if the if the device is not expensive i'll i'll sometimes buy another device just a fresh one i just
plug it in and run the exploit just just plug it in i don't do anything else because it might surprise you
but sometimes like sometimes like weird things happen like the first time that you visit the device
there is the ajax call on the http request that sets the time zone of the device without you knowing it
and right at this on stage the the zdi device is fresh out of the box and maybe they didn't visit the first
page and then your exploit is failing and you're like why is it failing and maybe it's because well just
because nobody has ever visited this certain page which normally that's a very specific example
yeah it's like very weird stuff that's that's crazy yeah and that's great
crazy crazy stuff yeah that yeah one thing i think uh from before uh i kind of like did an example about
when you have bugs with like uh which is like a chain of multiple stuff and then the more complex the bug is
the better because then when you do you don't fully do you do like a partial dupe uh one of the thing is
like another example will be imagine you're exploiting a memory corruption and then uh when you're exploiting
it uh did this actually happen in one of the recent competitions that i went to uh for some reason uh
when i was doing the memory corruption i've managed to i managed to pull it off to the memory corruption
without the need to find the information disclosure and leaked any addresses from a like to defeat aslr
because i was like right in my rob chain i was relying on some addresses which weren't getting
randomized but one of the team was clever enough that thought okay let's instead make our exploit harder
and we find an info leak and add it to our chain even though they didn't need to but they just made their
exploit more difficult because they thought okay if they did like a random draw and then we didn't go
first and then we went second or third at least our our exploit is more complex so we don't do like a
full do a partial to at least which is which is a smart and zedra actually that's like encourages you to
do so yeah wow very cool yeah thanks for sharing that i think i think those sort of things are exactly
what we want to know about going into these competitions right having that sort of metagaming
aspect how do you how do you um play the environment properly so that you can maximize your return
um so that's that's really helpful stuff um okay man i think i've got a picture right i think i've got
a picture of what it looks like to do um uh pwn to own a little bit more um the last the only thing
other thing that i wanted to talk about was uh the point uh the master of pwn title right so um in a in
a pwn to own environment is there there's just one winner you know everybody who has a successful
exploit is considered a winner of a pwn to own or whatever and then there's one person that comes
out as the master of pwn um is there is there any awards for like second or third or fourth place or is
it just that one master pwn title yeah yeah so people go to pwn to own they are i think the sentence is
maybe i'm doing the grammar right or wrong uh they are a winner at point to not winner of the pwn to
own right so okay they're not winning the whole thing but they're just they're just one of the one
of the many winners at poll two right and then sometimes there is this like uh crazy uh geniuses
who who managed to win pwn to own and then the whole thing and then they will be nominated as master
of pawn uh which can be only one there is no second place no third place it's just one place and then
wow they get a a statue of reward like a trophy which is always different uh either it's like a
i don't know a signed basketball in like a cool cage or uh like a statue of a of a of a beetle of a bug
or something or something which is just like a token of appreciation and also a certain amount of money
and also i think uh let me let me just make sure uh uh that i'm saying this right uh um so with with
zdi's you have something called a status which is uh so so a lot of people know but uh zdi purchases
uh purchases bugs uh and uh when they purchase these bugs uh you get some points uh like i think
it's i think it's similar to like signal or whatever in hacker one um uh sure i think so
yeah but they call it like yeah yeah exactly so you you got like points you got you got you got the
status you you gather points and then you reach a status with this point points for example 15 000
points uh will get you a bronze status and then 25 000 points is silver and then it's gold and it's
platinum uh which is the maximum status that you can have and when you win ponte on as a master of
pawn when you win the whole thing uh you instantly get a platinum status on your account and these
statuses what they do is basically yeah exactly and what they do is they um whenever you submit a
buck to zdi and then these the researchers will like review it reproduce it make sure it's legit and
all of that and then it's cool when they want to purchase it based on your status they do a
multiplication on the amount of money they're going to give you uh uh that uh so if you're like platinum
maybe you get double of the money if if you were supposed to get five grand for an rc on a product
you get like 10 grand right uh based on the status that you have on on the zdi zdi platform uh yeah uh
that's pretty much it and also uh what i said the the more complex the box is in the chain you get
like partial dupin that's like a technique to use it's because uh don't don't forget zdi is buying the
bug and also is buying your technique so if you made your exploit more complex to adding more
buck chains to it it's good for them as well because you're giving them more techniques to learn about
uh so you're like selling more techniques yeah that's it's very cool that they've found this a
a profitable business model with their with their um you know product essentially the result of this
uh you know it's a lot of uh you know it's a lot of uh you know it's a lot of uh you know it's a lot
of uh you know it's a lot of uh you know it's a lot of uh you know it's a lot of uh you know
how to do you know how to do this works a little bit differently oh go ahead go ahead sorry
bad habit jumping in people's talking no no no i want to hear that i want to hear that tell me that
okay do you know how how point one started no no i don't okay uh so uh with with pawn tool and the way it
started as far as i as far as i know at the cansec west which is a security conference in vancouver
canada um back in the day uh i don't remember the exact date maybe 2016 or 17 or maybe 15 i don't know
one of those uh times uh zdi was still like purchasing bugs and zdi was a thing and then uh can
sequence organizer uh asked the crowd that uh back in the time people were like always saying like macbook
is the secure or whatever and then uh they've asked if any anyone from the audience can hack a
macbook remotely remote code execution and if they do if they pawn it they can own it and then they asked
so zdi was was there a sale as well i think as a sponsor or something and then they asked zdi if zdi
is willing to purchase the bug and zdi says said yes we will purchase it for 10 000 if anyone can do it
and then somebody actually did they they found a way between a macbook it's crazy at the time
they they found a rc in macbook quicktime and then they exploited remotely and then uh pontoon kind
of started from there initially it was only browsers they were only like doing like i don't know like
safari chrome uh internet explorer at the time and then uh after that uh it kind of like evolved into
a lot of more devices virtualizations vmware virtual box uh like enterprise solutions sharepoint
exchange and then microsoft teams and then it kind of evolved into uh mobile devices which is like
samsung sony xiaomi apple google and then like enterprise solutions like uh iot devices smart home
speakers printers and then also and then after that it was like ics products which is like scada products
like right you know like critical uh critical solutions and then after that it evolved into
automotive which is the newest type of thing uh which is like infotainment systems smart dv chargers
and all of that and zdi started from paying hundreds of thousands like like 300 000 400 000
total at one competition to now paying over millions now like they like they pay like at a
single competition they pay over a million now and then which is crazy so the competition is way
way way more now it's much more uh and there's this there's a sad truth to to one other thing as well
as back in the day it was either solo researchers or a team of like two or three people just like solo
people now people are competing who are coming from companies like company sponsor teams who have like
i don't know 40 50 employees at the company and they're paying the paying the employee salary
uh so no limit on that to work on these products so it's crazy like if if a solo researcher is working
on it uh they're not getting paid until they find the bug right but imagine you work for a company
who's paying your salary so you know like if you're going to look at it like eight to five eight to five
you're going to get your salary at the end of the month so so you have that calmness you don't you
don't have any stress on it and then uh right uh those people will will like 20 people come to the
competition right so and then you're not competing against a team of two or three you're competing
against a company of 20 people and they're doing it to get pr which which makes sense kind of but
i'm just i'm just saying it putting it out there even though it is it is a well-known thing but for
anyone who doesn't know things get more difficult when you're competing against a company who has
so so imagine if if when i'm competing um i'm rever i'm i'm breaking the hardware attacking the
hardware reversing uh fuzzing uh writing the exploit myself when that company is doing it they have five
experts who only understand hardware since they were a little kid they were designing pcbs and then
just like just building like hardware right right so they give the device to there so the initial
stage was getting a shell on the device right they get a shell on the device in two hours because
they're five seasons hardware like experts right they get it in two hours and then they pass it on
to the next department who are like experts in writing fuzzers they write the fuzzers they pass it on to
the next apartment meantime like they're they're working on different time zones 24 7. the research has
never stopped never paused and they go and then people like me or someone else show up a solo guy a
one-man army two-man army three-man army show up and uh they're competing against these teams right
which is crazy that is crazy that's very people should know crazy it's hard yeah wow dude well
it seems like the competition has evolved a lot over the years and uh you know hopefully we'll see
some accommodations for you know researchers that are going at it more more single-handedly versus
these these big teams but also you know um as the game changes our approaches to the game has to
change and we've seen that in the hacker one bug bounty world as well um you know just trying to
to build collaboration um units essentially uh and and also you know building automation out to try to
help with these sort of things and but that also highlights one of the main differences between the
zdi competitions and the hacker one world which is this is probably the biggest difference is zdi only
pays for remote code execution and you know at a hack one event you know there's normally two three four
or five um you know remote code executions but uh there's like 700 other volumes you know um and and
so uh once again when talking about the differences between these two worlds um the fact that we're able
to pay the bills with our little c-surf's in our in our xss's and our idors um while working on these
more complex exploits really i think makes it sustainable in the long term got a good point for us to be able to
continue to do bug bounty um whereas like you said before zdi the pontone competitions it's like hard
mode right you got to go in there who knows if if you know the the wheel stops on doesn't stop on your
number then there goes your car you know like and and uh there's a lot more volatility to the process
and uh and then also the exploits accepted are much more um are much more have to be much more technical
will have to be much more um rce oriented than than maybe even business logic oriented or or impact to the actual
uh target ecosystem oriented um so very very interesting to see those differences there
yeah and uh there are some people that like so at the last point one that was held in vancouver
uh when i said like these like exactly this like rcs only and then uh the difficulty of competing
against these companies is um this guy whose name is manfred paul um yeah i don't know if you know him
but he he he came in one guy exploited all the browsers edge safari firefox chrome all of them all of
them exploited by one guy holy moly and he he's this crazy dude and he won the competition like a lot
of companies were there i'm not naming names but a lot of companies were there and then he managed to
win it and he's exceptionally talented we're talking about someone who who who's like i think he's out of
this world i don't know like how one percent of the one percent reaches exactly he he he he he's i i'm
not i can't even like analyze him to put him in into words like he is crazy but um yeah yeah with
ton to own it's hard mode it's rc uh a lot of a lot of factors like luck and a lot of other stuff but
it's it's it's an elite competition and i know people who are only doing it to prove prove to
themselves and challenge themselves to do it and mainly compared to the money part um but uh i think
if i were to do it and i think i will someday uh i think that would be the reason it's it's not as
because these incentives are good but more so like i would i would rather i would i would like to compete
in it i would like to be um you know just going back to the hacker one world um you know the master
of pwn for hacker one is the um is the the mvh the most valuable hacker and when you win you get
these these belts i'll point to you know back here these belts yeah yeah and and i i uh you know i i've
got those and i i would like to also conquer the world of uh of uh pwnt own but man you know when you're
up against people like this this guy that rolls in here this manfred dude that that rolls in there and
just demolishes all browsers in one in one attempt it's like wow uh that's definitely going to be a
challenge to go up against and and i i just can't imagine you know yeah i just i just can't believe
there's not more incentive there and because um this is so such a challenging thing that people are doing
um i do want to get your take on on one more thing before we wrap up which is um do you think that zdi
should in the pontone competition should accept bugs that are not uh rces in the future uh to compete
with the other bug bounty arena um because obviously you know there are some situations where it's like
oh i've got full auth bypass but i i don't have a way to turn this into rce there's just no way to turn
it into rce in this front end of the system you know or whatever there's lots of impactful bugs that
are out there that will just destroy a product but um those are not being paid for uh from from
in these competitions what are your what are your thoughts on that uh yeah so zdi uh well uh let's
let's look at it this way right um again it's their rules and it's not it's not really up to me
thinking like what what should they what should they or shouldn't they do but uh uh for some devices
like uh mobile phones things that like make sense like with mobile things i think they have like
exceptions saying that if if it's a mobile phone we allow connecting like a usb like a like a usb
something because a lot of there's a lot of stuff going on under over like the lightning protocol that
the cable on iphone uses like a lot of like a lot of lot of protocols go on there and a lot of people
haven't found memory corruptions uh like it is accepted on those or like for example on mobile
devices uh like phones like samsung xiaomi whatever they allow one click exploits as well so basically
you share a link and then when they click on the link okay so just like so and they do that and they
also when you have like if when you go to the go to the competition and you have a valid exploit but
you're not able to finish the exploit on stage but it is an actual valid exploit they also give you
some percent they offer you uh offer to you that they will still buy it from from you if you want to
but for a small percentage just to just so you don't feel like you've wasted your whole time it is not the
same price as you could have get uh but you couldn't finish the book and this is just like a token of
appreciation again for the researcher to say what is the numbers look like on that like are they like
half are they like 10 are they like uh i i don't have it in my mind i think it's different every time
uh it really depends gotcha yeah okay that makes sense all right man um i'm looking through this
document here um yeah i think i think we've covered most of the stuff that i wanted to cover with regards to
pwn to own and what the experience is like and your approach to hacking and that sort of thing
the the only other thing that i think we've got time for is i would like to have gone through some
of the bugs that you've uh reported recently um but i'll just ask you one question about the um
the what's up gold pre-auth rce um yeah and that you that you've logged about on your on your
website summoning.team um in this exploit you know there's there's a lot of um technical explanation
where you're going through the the code and i love how you know you show the trace of where you
know what function calls what and create that little graph and that sort of thing that's super
helpful for understanding all of this um i'm wondering so this is utilizing the uh wcf uh protocol
right within within uh this dotnet environment um and that's right so this is a this is a tcp-based
service is that is that accurate uh let me see here or was that the other one that yeah yeah yeah
so so the thing is uh so uh we have something called wcf windows communication foundation yeah
it's super easy to understand the way that you could put it is imagine it's rpc right if if if
yeah it's rpc right you're remotely calling procedures you're remotely calling methods right
they expose some sort of methods under code that you can call those methods remotely okay and then in
order for this call to happen it needs to go to a custom protocol there used to be dotnet remoting
which was very very vulnerable right and they deprecated it and introduced wcf which is this one
wcf is like an alternative to dot net remoting for this substitution yeah exactly this is xml based it
seems um and and so yeah it depends so you can yeah you can configure your double cf to use different kind
of like they call it like uh like different kind of bindings so you can have like http binding or tcp
binding like there's there's there is way more bindings but they're basically what these bindings
mean mean is uh like do you want it to be sent over http or tcp and if you choose http it most of the
times it goes through as like a soap so protocol which is made by microsoft itself yeah so you don't you
don't write the soap microsoft takes care of it for you they they make your calls into like soap
formatted things or you use the tcp way i mean like they call it tcp but everything is like all
of it's basically over tcp but the tcp binding what it does is it it's another custom protocol which
you're sending like some sort of like encoded bytes and stuff like that like a size it's like a
size field bit field like a structure and all of that like a like a like a protocol and then you send
it across which is also taken care of by microsoft but writing the exploit wise when you're dealing
with like a binding which is http at the at the end you can like write some sort of a python code to
send like a http request over and get it done with but if you're exploiting a tcp based binding you need
to write like a c-sharp client which was the other blog that i published which was a c-sharp client code to
write the exploits gotcha okay okay so um that that that all makes sense that cleared it up it's a way to do
rpc um a newer version of dotnet remoting exactly it could be over tcp it could be over http or soap or
whatever yeah just depending on what binder is being used um and and i'm wondering um so when we're
looking at these sort of obviously your your thing is dot net and you're you're really good at that um
uh what what is the what is how often are you seeing stuff in wcf versus just like a normal uh http
you know iis or whatever environment um and is this potentially an environment that uh researchers
might be sort of sleeping on uh within within a lot of enterprise applications or iot devices or whatever
yeah so with uh with with uh wcf i really recommend people to to look at it it's not something new that
i've been doing i've been doing it for years and years and i've been submitting like bugs about wcf a lot
of times it's just something that uh like people don't tend to blog about maybe about this so it
it keeps being like a little bit um not as well known even though if you google about like wcf
exploitation you will see blogs going back to like four years from now that we're talking or maybe three
years from now like maybe maybe from like 2020 or 2019 even uh people have exploited that people have
given talks about it people have written blog posts about it uh presentations and everything but you
don't see it being blocked about publicly a lot of times yeah as much as it might could it could be it
might might could have been uh but yeah i really recommend people to to to um basically start
understanding what wcf is start writing like some some sort of a custom lab environment and stuff build it
up and then try to like experiment with it understand it exploit it and all of that and then uh which
which we also do in our course by the way okay yeah yeah yeah so in the course there's there's like every
like i can i can bravely say like 80 percent of any kind of remote technology in dotnet that can happen
any kind of like rpc wcf dot and remote or a lot of other things that i don't want to name now because
i want to like keep it as like the secret sauce in the course sure i cover them all and how to exploit
them and how to audit them and how to write exploit clients for them and all of that uh but yeah uh it's
double safe is worth investigating and work working on yeah very cool i like that a lot um and and just one
one last question on that so um yeah you know this one is the one in the blog that i'm looking at right now
is listening on port 9642 and 9643. um if we see those those i seem that is specific to this application
this isn't on every single uh yeah so when we're looking for wcf services are we trying to track down
this uh like in this example it says nmapi.exe.config so is there normally like a dot dot
config file that we can look at to see where the the various routing is occurring and what kind of
bindings are being registered good question so when you're auditing wcf you're dealing with three
things address binding contract based on the microsoft documentation you're dealing with these
three things right uh you need to find the address the binding and the contract these are the three
things the address is the address like a slash nmapi whatever right the binding is the type of binding
that you're going to be talking to http tcp and many others there is not just just those two and then
contract is actually the code the methods that you want to invoke so uh when you want to exploit it you
need to find all you need to find or you need to write the interface for those contracts a contract is
basically the methods that the that the target server is offering to you that you can invoke so you
need to build it up and after you build these three up artist binding contract you need to if you work
on it and like just like read the blog and like google around maybe you can get to it and how that
you can like stick this together and then finish the exploit but the the the thing is uh whether there's
the question that you ask okay how can we now find this tree uh so it's not always a config file
it can even be in the code so there can be there can be no conflict well at all no conflict file at all
it's tricky you need to be also exactly you need to be able to decompile and look for a wcf setup and
registration and those addresses and binding and contracts in the code by decompiling it with like
the inspire whatever the compiler you want to use it's not always conflict files what are some some
keywords we should be looking at for that like for example i see in here basic http binding something
like that if we search exactly the word binding the word binding itself will give it out
binding perfect love that so so then that'll help us track down our sources right these are services
that are being um exposed and then we can sort of track the through the sinks exactly and that actually
makes me think of one more question i wanted to ask you there's a big debate on the podcast um you know
i think this is mostly um occurs when we have targets that we're looking at that doesn't have a
massive code base because if you have a massive code base you have to address things a little bit
differently but um do you normally start with sources or sinks and when you're doing a source code
uh analysis like are you normally looking at like um you know all right this is how there's like eight
services here and i'm going to go through every single function for every single service or do you
look for vulnerable code patterns and then work it back up to a source
um let me let me put it this way right this uh again i don't i don't i don't represent any like
like i don't know one abt researchers whatever this is just this is just me as a single person who's
answering this right um if you look at uh so yeah the answer the basic answer is i do all of them
um but let me elaborate a little bit um if we if we start with sinks and then work our way back to
sources like find dangerous things and then find out how can we hit them how can we reach them that's
good why bad like if it was bad it wasn't a method it is it is good i use it to this day as well now
but don't limit yourself to only that as well sometimes following sources to sink like sometimes just like
following sources doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you think they're gonna hit a sink or not just
following the sources let's just following them see what the heck is the app the application is going
to do with this that i'm going to be providing to you because sometimes if you only look for the sinks
uh sometimes there might be some sort of a logical bug which which isn't relying on a well-known sink or
or a sink that you might say but a kind of behavior that is dangerous to this certain application right
so it's always good to also follow the things and to follow follow the sources doesn't matter if you
know indeed that it's going to be hitting a sink so both of them sink to source source or sink that's
both good and that's okay a lot of my personal friends do the same thing too yeah yeah i think i
think that's what we all do i think i think um you know it also depends if you see a bunch of really
obvious stuff you might jump right into the sinks and try to trace your way back but what i always say is
if you spend time on sources you're never gonna like regret that time because it's time that you're
gonna understand more about that application spend understanding the application you know and um and
understanding how that's an amazing answer uh the application flows um and you're gonna get a better
feel intuitively for that app that will help you trace back up from the sources as well i mean from
the sinks as well does that make sense am i representing that correctly that you got it right on the
point perfect all right man wow um well this has been a long episode and uh a great one one of my
favorites so far for sure um i would love to have you come back on again sometime and discuss um a
little bit more of these nitty-gritty details about dot net and you know oh we're getting in here um you
know we're checking out these wcf services that sort of thing so we'll have to set that up again in the
future but um uh for now man uh cena thank you so much for coming on and uh anything you want to shout
out before we end the podcast uh yeah of course uh thank you very much first of all let me take you
that take you take you up on that offer uh whatever uh whatever you you feel like uh please give me uh
give me like uh give me a ping give me a shout out and then i'll show up we can do like a session
i'll share my screen or whatever and we exploited dotnet vulnerability i don't know we exploit a exchange
server a ias server we exploited tricky dot net based targets or whatever um i'm happy to do so
uh did you you you've you've guys built up a great platform and i like to contribute to it because i
know it has a good spotlight on it and uh it helps me and you at the same time i think uh so i appreciate
i appreciated you having me here that's first uh second one is i just wanted to give a few shoutouts
to some people who who've who've helped me a lot and then i i remember the name uh i've tried to
to write them in a note so you're gonna be looking at me and thinking that i'm reading reading from
something and that's right uh let me let me just uh let me just bring it up um yeah so i just first i
want to give a shout out to uh to the zero day initiative uh zdi uh like um they have been always
supportive of my work and uh like helped me to to get into the competition and show up especially
brian gorans uh as i said who's the vice president of uh thread research at trend micro and also dustin
childs who's the head of thread awareness these are like two lovely folks who were like always always
helping me uh through pontoon and just like making making a dream happen basically next i want to thank
uh michael michael michael de plant he's a he's actually a zdi employee he's a researcher there um
and uh he's such a great guy he he sometimes he he he runs my attempts on on pontoon and then uh when
he runs them he's always like he's he's a calm person and that helps me to run my attempts really
good so shout out to him as well uh i want to give a shout out to uh uh shout out sorry i want to give
a shout out to radic and uh radic from flashback team uh i don't know if you know him uh he and
pedro rivero both of them uh bradick and pedro shout out to both of you uh they're both great people
they have a hardware hardware exploitation training that you can go to uh these two these two guys uh
pedro and radic uh i think the only reason that i got into hardware exploitation was because of these
people i personally never took their training but i i know for a fact that their training is phenomenal
and i i've only learned uh i've only learned my starter dot net exploit uh sorry hardware exploitation
i talked about a lot about dotnet but my hardware exploitation from their public research and public
blog posts and they were the reason that i got into hardware expectation i want to give a give a shout
out to my dear friend surush surush dalili he's he's like he's always been an idol to me what a legend
he's one of my best friends like he has i can say like everything that i know about dotnet is because
of him and that's it like it's because of him like uh i shouldn't be honestly i shouldn't be i shouldn't
have a dotnet exploitation training he should have it but for some reason uh i don't know the up is down
i'd something i don't know you know all over like reverse everything and then uh i'm doing the training
um and also steven silly mr me he he's he's the only reason that i've got into one ability research i
just like i've been trying to follow his his footsteps and everything and uh he he's all i've still haven't
reached his level but i i'm seeing that i'm i'm stepping on the right path and another shout out
uh to two other people and i will promise you i'm done uh chadip uh chadi works at uh trend micro as
well he he always does phenomenal dotnet research and dotnet exploitation and he's always a inspiration
to my training to my experts to everything dotnet that i do he's always an inspiration to my work i i get
inspired so much from his work and also orange side for basically like shifting the whole infosec like
concept to like another level like he always like brings up with with crazy other stuff there's a lot
of other people who i've who who are here that i i like to give a shout out but these were all them
uh and one other person and lastly is is the guy that i who i said at the beginning uh may sam once if
he he was he was a mentor a teacher a friend to me and he's always be and i've learned a ton from him
and maybe if it wasn't because of him i wouldn't be doing infosec at all wow yeah that's it sorry
that was legendary i think one of the things about you that i've gotten the impression from from this is that you
you are very grateful and you're very humble and even just in your times when we're off camera
during this podcast like you've always been very accommodating and you've been very grateful that
you're that you know you're able to be here and i feel you know i feel like it's vice versa man i feel
like i'm so lucky to have you on the podcast and get your your um your takes on all this stuff so um
that's the best situation right where we're both grateful and happy and uh pleased to have each other so
um thank you so much for coming on man and and i just wanted to say uh thank you of that list uh
sarush obviously a legend but uh chuddy p uh same for orange but chuddy pb is someone that just came
on my radar recently with this uh sharepoint xxc that came out and um i actually had a note in this
episode to talk about uh his research on the sharepoint xxc because um he he echoes something that you
mentioned as well with with the um the debugger being so important which is that you can validate
your assumptions instead of guessing and in his research he um he he exploits and this is the
processing was disabled yeah exactly that's exactly it man the dtd processing was disabled and the xml
resolver was set to a bunch of different stuff and is like wow why would you even try xxc when you
see this and i think it's because you have more introspection into the environment and see what's
actually going on so debugger um yeah is definitely on my uh on my on my tweet mention on my like tweet
notifications on this now um so yeah all right man his name is what by the way what sorry by the way uh
when i when i said these people's names uh maybe i used their handle or something try this try this
name is pewter uh just want to just want to say it and uh sorry for the for the long list uh i i didn't
get a lot of i didn't get a lot of chance to to be on something that will be seen or heard by people
and when i am uh i've got to give give shout out to those people because if it wasn't because of them
i wouldn't be here honestly and thank you so much for having me here of course dude of course man that
gratitude it warms the heart and and for anybody you know that's listening that's thinking wow that was
a long list hey now you've got a list to go and look at and people to follow and follow look into because
those are the people that have made uh cena who he is you know and and you know clearly they've got
a lot to offer the world so um all right thank you so much man great podcast and that's a wrap on this
episode of critical thinking thanks so much for listening and if you want more critical thinking
content head over to ctvv.show discord join the discord there's lots of great conversations and chats
going on over there and if you want to support the show there's the discord subscriber tiers which give
you access to master classes amas hack alongs exclusive scripts and an exclusive chat channel with us
we'll see you there